[Musique]
Alain Grand Jean. Bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Donc j'ai créé et je suis associé d'une
société de conseil qui s'appelle Carbon
4. Euh par ailleurs, je suis président
de la fondation Nicolas pour la pour la
nature et l'homme. Et enfin, je tiens un
blog qui s'appelle les chroniques de
l'entreposè.
Vous avez quoi comme background ? J'ai
fait des études d'ingénieur généraliste
l'école polytechnique ensuite de
l'économie au sein d'une école qui
s'appelle Lensae. Ensuite, j'ai
travaillé pour faire une thèse de
doctorat en économie de l'environnement
et après j'ai fait une carrière dans
l'industrie et il y a quelques années,
c'est-à-dire une quinzaine d'années, je
me suis remis entièrement aux questions
d'environnement.
Et pourquoi à l'époque c'était en quelle
année votre doctorat ?
1983.
Et l'écologie comme ça ça vous est venu
? J'ai de la génération Club de Rome.
La génération Club de Rome, c'est les
quelques personnes comme moi qui ont été
très très frappées par le rapport au
Club de Rome sur les limites à la
croissance. Donc il paraît au milieu des
années 70. Moi, je suis rentré à la
poltechnique en 75. Donc, j'ai été très
frappé par ça. C'est la la une période
post 68 en fait hein. Et donc, il y a eu
un un gros mouvement. Moi, je faisais
partie de ces gens qui étaient euh euh
motivés par ça. Donc, j'ai toujours été
intéressé par les questions d'écologie.
Et l'économie, c'est parce que de dès le
départ euh je j'ai pensé que les
questions économiques et écologiques
étaient liées. Alors après, j'ai fait
tout à fait autre chose dans ma carrière
parce que à l'époque faire ces
travailler sur ces sujets-là, c'était
quand même très compliqué.
Compliqué pourquoi ? pour qu'il y avait
très très peu d'emplois, il y avait très
peu de postes et moi j'ai j'ai fait un
peu de la recherche pendant 4 ans
puisque j'ai fait une thèse et je crois
que c'était pas tout à fait fait pour
moi. J'avais aussi un côté euh assez
concret opérationnel donc j'ai après été
très content de faire une vie
industrielle
qui s'est composé d'eux et vous avez
fait quoi ?
J'ai été euh responsable
euh
financier et puis directeur général
adjoint d'une entreprise industrielle,
une grosse PME dans le sud-ouest de la
France.
Comment ça s'appelle ? Euh, elle
s'appelait Sou à l'époque.
Il faisait quoi de beau ?
Il faisait du matériel électrique et
puis aussi du matériel de transport
ferroviaire.
Bon, on va revenir à nos moutons.
L'écologie, la planète, la finance, la
financiarisation du monde. Euh euh on
fait d'abord un petit constat sur notre
climat, sur l'état de la planète. Oui,
je l'ai appelé les chroniques
d'entreposé de mon blog parce que je
suis très convaincu de cet enjeu les le
fait qu'on est dans une période très
particulière de de l'histoire de la
planète et de l'espèce humaine dans
laquelle l'espèce humaine joue à jeu
égal mais parfois supérieur en fait
contre les forces naturelles. Premier
exemple, c'est des milliards de tonnes
de matériaux qui sont déplacés chaque
année par l'espèce humaine. On fait des
calculs de coin de table et on
s'aperçoit que c'est l'ordre de grandeur
de ce que fait la nature par des
tremblements de terre, du volcanisme et
cetera. Les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de que produit l'activité humaine
sont beaucoup plus puissantes pour faire
bouger le climat que l'évolution
naturelle le fait depuis des milliers
d'années. Donc
volcan quand même ça émet vachement de
soufre non ? Oui oui mais le le le je ce
que je disais tout à l'heure il y a des
il y a des calculs qui montrent qu'il y
a je sur certains sujets mais pour les
gaz effet de ser qui sont des gaz très
précis qui sont le CO2
le méthane le protoxyde d'azote plus
tout un tas de gaz fluurés il y a pas de
doute que les émissions de gazf et de
ser dans l'atmosphère sont nature à
faire bouger euh la température moyenne
planétaire beaucoup plus vite que ce que
fait euh la nature par elle-même. Donc
les ordres de grandeur, c'est que on
prend 5°gr de plus ou de moins entre une
glacière et une interglaciaire. Donc là,
on est dans une interglaciaire, la
dernière glaciaire, c'est il y a 20000
ans. 5°gr de moins en moyenne
température planétaire sur 1 an
là et donc on remonte la température en
10000 ans grossièrement et là en 100 ou
200 ans on va on peut faire une
variation de température de 5°gr aussi.
Donc on va beaucoup plus vite que la
nature sur ce sujet-là. Donc dans
certains cas, on fait je égal. dans
d'autres, on est plus puissant. Donc
c'est pour ça que c'est pas anecdotique
de de parler d'entrreopine.
Alors l'entropocène ça veut dire
ça veut dire que c'est une période donc
on décompose des périodes géologiques en
en période en sous-période et là on
entrerait. Ça reste ça reste à être
décidé parce que c'est les commissions
de stratégigraphie donc c'est tout un
tout un protocole scientifique très très
élaboré qui dénommerait
la période dans lequelle on rentre avec
un débat sur la période est-ce que c'est
1950 ? parce que c'est un peu avant un
peu après nouvelle période qui un
nouveau régime dans lequel on constate
c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle anthropo
scène dans lequel on on acte le fait que
l'espèce humaine a un rôle spécial dans
la vie de la planète.
Ce rôle
est-ce que l'humanité en a pris
réellement conscience ? Est-ce que le
business on a pris conscience ? Est-ce
que la finance en a pris conscience ?
Il y a des prises de conscience
partielles,
donc très profondes dans certains
domaines scientifiques.
Évidemment, les climatologues qui
manipulent les données dont je parle
depuis des décennies, ça ils ont
compris. Euh il y a des disciplines
scientifiques qui s'en foutent
complètement parce que c'est pas leur
sujet. Donc il y a des spécialités.
Après au niveau de l'espèce humaine dans
son ensemble, on est très nombreux. Donc
je suis incapable de savoir ce que pense
chacun de mes 8 milliards de de
contemporains. Le business, ça dépend
des coins. Il y a des chefs
d'entreprises qui ont un peu compris le
truc, d'autres s'en foutent
complètement. C'est très hétérogène. La
réalité, c'est que c'est très hétérogène
et globalement collectivement, je pense
qu'on est loin du compte si je dois
faire une réponse synthétique.
Les gouvernements,
on va dire des des des gouvernements de
pays occidentaux,
ils font quoi ? Ils font de la
procrastination,
ils font du wishful sinking,
ils font ils font ils font ils font quoi
? Ils sculptent de la fumée, il brassent
de l'air chaud, ils mangent des petits
fours, ils font des petits sommets, ils
convoquent les climatologues anonymes
pour prendre des décisions.
Ouais. Donc sur le climat parce qu'après
il y a un énorme sujet qui s'appelle la
biodiversité dont on parlera quand même
2 minutes
à travers la pollution avant.
Euh ouais, enfin on parlera tout ça tout
à l'heure mais juste sur le climat parce
que là la documentation est assez
claire. Ça fait 20 30 ans que les
scientifiques du climat alertent sur le
fait qu'il y a un vrai problème et qu'il
faut s'en occuper. Deuxièmement, disent
quelles sont les causes et donc il y a
pas tellement de débats scientifiques
sur la question. Et de dans ces
décenniesl avance très très très
lentement. Or c'est un sujet de bien
commun et donc le marché l'activité
décentralisée des acteurs économiques,
elle seule c'est sûr qu'elle elle peut
pas le faire. Elle arrivera pas à
résoudre le problème à elle seule. Donc,
on a besoin
de la puissance publique et donc forcé
de constater que cette puissance
publique a largement traîné pour prendre
en en main ce problème. Cela étant, et
c'est pas une excuse, nous sommes en
démocratie et j'ai quand même
l'impression que dans des régimes
démocratiques,
les politiques sont à la remorque de
l'opinion.
J'ai quand même cette impression là.
Bah, ils sont à la remorque. Pourquoi ?
Parce que ils font ils font des mesures
doivent être élus. parce qu'ils doivent
être élus et donc si l'opinion euh
est est pas sensible au problème parce
qu'elle met du temps à être sensible, le
politique suit l'opinion.
Et d'ailleurs c'était alors
pour parler entre pour lire entre vos
lignes appelons un chinche, appliquer
des mesures drastiques pour sauver le
climat engagerait des répercussions sur
les les classes moyennes, les classes
sociales, la population qui les
conduirait peut-être à être grognon face
aux politiques qui les mettraient en
place.
Euh c'est évident qu'il y a
c'est très trivial, mais est-ce que ça
fonction ?
Non, non, non. Ben, ça c'est clair que
il y a il y a il y a il y a ce côté-là.
Euh il y a il y a des des gens comme
Churchill qui ont promis euh du sang de
l'essieur et des larmes et ils ont
réussi à faire bouger euh le leur euh
le économie de guerre
leur économie de guerre parce que
l'opinion était totalement convaincu
qu'il fallait y aller. Donc le
en matière de de climat, j'ai
l'impression que il y a un frémissement
de l'opinion en ce moment. C'est pas
juste les européennes hein, c'est que
j'ai des mouvements de jeunes très
forts. C'est je pense que c'est pas
anecdotique et ça révèle bien le fait
que là euh les opinions sont en train de
bouger. Il y a pas que du tout dans le
domaine du climat dans les histoires par
exemple santé environnement, les
questions de de pollution diffuse, les
questions de rapport à la santé. Euh moi
je constate parce que là j'ai un peu de
recul et d'expérience euh je constate un
nouveau rapport de l'opinion à la
nourriture, un nouveau rapport au risque
sanitaire
et des choses qui permettent à des
gouvernements de prendre des mesures un
peu plus euh courageuses. Disons le mot.
Alors, on dit tout le temps, l'écologie
c'est un sport de bobo, c'est un sport
de riche, c'est un sport de de celui qui
peut s'acheter un petit peu de bio, qui
peut
Non, on les discrédite souvent comme ça.
Ouais.
Est-ce que Est-ce que l'écologie à
grande échelle, ça ça répond à à nos
besoins d'une société en pleine
mondialisation ? Ah, d'abord, il y a il
y a faut faut comprendre les enjeux tels
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui. C'est-à-dire
tels qui sont aujourd'hui euh les
désastres écologiques annoncé et pas
dans des horizons infinis. Donc
relativement court terme court terme
bah dans les années c'est en ce moment
d'abord pour commencer on va le désastre
c'est les désastres c'est
euh des des effets de de sécheresse ou
d'incendie
des qui donc là les gens qui sont au
bord de c'est dans dans ces coinsl bah
ils souffrent ils sont en difficulté les
les changements de régime de mousson en
Inde ça a des effets tragiques sur sur
la situation des gens qui qui
s'organisent d'une certaine manière les
inond fondation,
c'est tragique aussi. Donc il y a des
aujourd'hui dès aujourd'hui des milliers
de personnes, des millions de personnes
qui qui vivent des des
qui souffrent des changements
intempestifs de du climat.
Vous étudiez aussi les les répercussions
du changement climatique sur les partis
politiques, les gouvernements.
Je reviens quand même au au point sur
les pauvres les dans les pauvres les
bobos, hein. Juste un tout petit point
pour terminer pour que ce soit clair
pour tout le monde, c'est que évidemment
que c'est pas une affaire de Bobo, c'est
une affaire de chacun d'entre nous. va
ou non pouvoir s'adapter à des
conditions très difficiles. Évidemment
que la capacité d'adaptation, elle est
plus faible euh pour des gens qui ont
moins de ressources et moins de capacité
au sens très large des termes. Donc les
désastres écologiques sont très injustes
sur le plan social. Il a là-dessus, il y
a c'est bon consensus, c'est assez clair
ça.
En gros, c'est c'est les plus pauvres
qui vont morfler en premier. Et
c'est ça que je veux dire. Voilà.
Voilà. Vous avez vous avez un ami qui
est Jean-Marc Jeancovici
euh si je me rappelle d'une de ses
conférences, il nous dit en gros pour
pas ralentir mais partir sur un
réchauffement à 2 degrés sur une
prévision à 2 degrés, il faudrait
diminuer le PIB par tête par 6.
C'est clair ce que je vous dis ?
Euh ça j'entends ce que vous dites. Euh
moi je suis pas complètement convaincu
de de ces de ce type de calcul. ça me
paraît pas si facile que ça à se
projeter dans l'avenir. Le PIB, c'est un
indicateur macroéconomique que moi je
trouve pas très intéressant, pas très
convainquant.
Et ce que j'espère principalement, c'est
que on arrive à s'organiser socialement
avec des indicateurs très différents du
PIB. Bon, après de manière définitive,
il y a une corrélation complète entre la
hausse de la température et la
croissance du PIB, je je pense que c'est
des paris. On sait pas trop. Donc moi,
ce qui me semble plutôt à pointer du
doigt, c'est
c'est que on sait que pour
respecter l'accord de Paris, c'est
limiter la température moyenne
planétaire à en dessous de plus de
degrés par rapport à celle qu'il était
au milieu du 19e siècle. Il faut réduire
fortement et drastiquement nos émissions
de gaz effet de serre. Ça on sait on
sait qu'aujourd'hui
le contenu en en émission de gaz à effet
de serre du PIB est est tel que si on
change rien à nos dispositifs
sociotechniques, le les conclusions
s'imposent. Soit on respecte pas
l'accord de Paris, soit euh
et donc on crève avec des plein de
désastres.
Voilà et et soit dans dans les
conditions actuelles, on fera de la de
la baisse du du PIB. Le seul petit
problème, c'est que nos les conditions
sociotechniques, c'est la manière dont
on aimait du CO2, la manière dont on
aimait du méthane, elle se bouge. Donc
c'est pas clair du tout que on fera la
même chose pendant 50 ans dans les dans
les 50 ans qui viennent. C'est même
presque sûr que c'est le contraire. Si
je prends encore un exemple, illustrer
ma pensée, euh si on se projette en
1950, on essaie de voir comment
fonctionne l'agriculture en 1950
et on regarde qu'est-ce qu'elle devient
50 ans après, le changement est massif.
Il y avait 6 millions d'agriculteurs en
en et d'exploitation agricole en 1950.
Il y en a moins de 10 fois moins 50 ans
après. L'organisation l'agriculture, je
dis pas qu'elle s'est améliorée ou pas
amélioré. C'est pas mon c'est pas mon
point à ce stade. C'est juste de dire
les évolutions sont quand même très
fortes.
On se on on continue sur le climat, sur
le l'état des lieux de la planète où on
commence à aborder les solutions, les
vecteurs de changement. Non, je pense
qu'on peut dire 2 minutes sur sur la
question d'érosion de la biodiversité
parce que euh la question climatique,
elle est sur le devant de la scène
depuis très longtemps et euh on
bénéficie de ce point de vue-là de la de
la de l'organisation très très
remarquable euh de cette communauté de
climatologue et du fait qu'il y a ce
groupe intergonental d'experts sur le
climat qui euh qui a qui rend ses
rapports qui fait qui fait pas qui fait
une synthèse de tous les travaux
scientifique et ce tous les 5 6 ans.
C'est c'est absolument extraordinaire.
La biodiversité s'est organisée de
manière beaucoup plus tardive et donc
maintenant elle commence à faire la même
chose avec les les les
travaux de l'IPBES qui est donc
l'équivalent à peu près. C'est pas tout
à fait la même chose mais ça ressemble
quand même. Et là on s'aperçoit que les
travaux de synthèse de cette IPBS c'est
que le front de la biodiversité se porte
très mal. Pourquoi il se porte très mal
? Bah parce que les constats qui sont
faits sont alarmants aussi.
Euh non pas parce que les scientifiques
sont des des paranoïques ou des malades
mentaux, c'est juste que la situation
est pas bonne. On sait euh et on
constate une très grosse érosion de la
biodiversité. Or, nous, les êtres
humains, on a beaucoup besoin euh
des ressources biologiques et elles sont
en danger aujourd'hui. Donc le panorama
du rapport entre l'espèce humaine et son
environnement au sens très large qui
soit le climat, la biodiversité,
la qualité de l'eau est un panorama qui
qui monte qu'à l'évidence, il va falloir
des modifications très substantielles et
très très profondes de de notre
organisation économique pour en sortir.
Alors ces fameuses modifications, ça ça
prendrait quelle ébauche ?
Avec grande ligne directrice ? de mon
point de vue, c'est
le faitement vert,
c'est plus profond que ça. et que si si
on va le dire d'une manière très très
simple, les c'est ce que j'ai pas mal de
développé, c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'il y a un petit une petite île de
pack dans mon dans mon blog, c'est que
en gros les la manière qu'on a tous les
uns et les autres de se représenter la
vie économique, c'est une manière qui
repose sur une représentation
très bizarre quand on réfléchit 2
minutes qui est qu'on ne compte que des
euros ou des dollars ou des choses comme
ça dans dans nos comptes hein
d'entreprise, dans nos comptes publics
et cetera. Et cette représentation là ne
nous fait pas voir du tout des choses
qui ne sont pas monétaires. Or, à
l'évidence, la nature, elle se fait pas
payer pour les services,
la pollinisation des abeilles,
le climat tel qu'il est, euh la qualité
de l'air, il y a tout un tas
d'équilibres et même
les fourmis, les champignons dans le
sang.
Mais même le pétrole, le pétrole c'est
quand vous achetez du pétrole, c'est une
métonie. Vous achetez pas du pétrole,
vous achetez un service que vous rend un
producteur ou un transporteur qui vous
qui lui-même achète un service, ainsi de
suite. Et à la fin de l'histoire quand
vous regardez, c'est Mire Nature qui
vous met à disposition du pét qu'elle a
fabriqué il y a quelques millions
d'années. Bon, donc elle ça là à cet
endroit-là, il y a pas il y a pas de
carnet chèque,
il y a pas de facture, il y a rien du
tout. Donc et pour revenir au climat
pour prendre un autre exemple quand vous
balancez nous balançons du CO2 dans
l'atmosphère c'est une action de
recyclage he de de de retraitement on va
dire ça comme ça puisquil y a une partie
de ce CO2 qui est quand même réabsorbé
par les océans et et la forêt. Si ça se
réchauffe, c'est euh pas tout à fait
assez est repris par les océans et la
forêt mais ce service-là de retraitement
on va dire ça comme ça, il est gratos.
Il est il est pas payé. Donc notre
système économique est très bizarre et
fonctionne comme si toutes ces chosesl,
toutes ces merveilles là, elles étaient
gratuites sans prix. Donc évidemment,
tous les systèmes économiques, tout le
système de management, la manière dont
on compte nos profits, dont on compte
nos résultats, notre performance, elle
est elle ignore totalement le rapport de
l'espèce humaine à la nature. C'était
peut-être pas très gênant il y a de
siècles, c'était peut-être pas très
gênant il y a 50 ans. Aujourd'hui, ça
devient une grave erreur. Donc la
refonte de nos systèmes, elle commence
déjà par ça. compter vraiment autrement
euh pour prendre des décisions qui ne
sont pas des catastrophes par rapport à
cet enjeu naturel. On on aura pas qui
qui va faire ça ? Qui va instaurer ça ?
C'est le pouvoir politique qui va le
décider, l'imposer, c'est le pouvoir
politique qui qui dirige ? C'est
l'opinion publique qui va le réclamer ?
Alors, modifier en substance et en
profondeur euh la manière dont on prend
nos décisions économiques et dont gère
ça, ça va se faire par des mouvements
d'ensemble. Et donc, je crois pas un
instant à un DUC Machina qui va dire "ça
y est, c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire,
je j'ai rêvé la vérité."
Euh mais je crois un asi à des
mécanismes progressifs euh de prise en
considération de ces sujets.
Alors, progressif sur combien de temps ?
Alors, il faudrait aller très vite et je
crois qu'on va pas aller aussi vite
qu'il le faudrait. Donc,
donc c'est du wishful sinking ce qu'on
ce qu'on
Non, parce que euh il se passe pas rien.
Ah, il se passe pas rien. Donc je je
vais prendre un exemple pour être très
concret et puis après on en rediscutera
parce qu'il y a plein d'autres exemples.
Mais une manière de dire euh je mets un
prix à la nature qui est qui qui
s'intègre dans les comptes des acteurs,
c'est cette fameuse histoire de taxe
carbone. Donc là, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
On dit euh j'aimais une j'aimais un
polluant euh je dois payer un quelque
chose en contrepartie du fait que
j'aimais un polluant. Ça ça s'appelle la
tasse carbone. Donc il y a plein de
mécanismes qui le font. Ils sont extra
comptables parce que faire de la réforme
profonde de la comptabilité ça va
prendre un peu de temps. Mais c'est un
sujet qui est débattu qui est un sujet
qui devient un sujet de société. Et la
bonne nouvelle, je crois euh des
dernières
des derniers mois, c'est qu'on se rend
compte qu'on n'est pas à côté de la vie
économique et sociale, mais on est bien
dans la vie économique et sociale. Donc
on commence à comprendre que c'est pas
anecdotique, c'est-à-dire que on va
mettre en place des dispositions qui
changent un peu les équilibres sociaux,
qui changent le
la manière que les uns et les autres
vont avoir de vivre et de consommer. Et
donc c'est en train de se faire euh
simplement peut-être pas assez vite
évidemment. Euh
c'est quoi vite ?
Bah vite, je vais prendre un exemple
très concret.
C'est demain en fait qu'il faut le
faire.
Il faut le faire. Euh je suis pas un
dictateur tout-puissant. Donc si on se
dit on fait un truc vite fort et que
dans dans une démocratie
les les citoyens sont pas du tout
d'accord, c'est compliqué.
Il faut faire plus de propagande. Il
faut faire comme une propagande de
guerre comme a fait Churchild
en en identifiant les ennemis. Quels
sont les réels ennemis ? C'est le
consommateur,
c'est l'entreprise, c'est le pouvoir
public Quel est l'ennemi ? L'ennemi
c'est les pour le climat c'est les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Oui, mais qui fait ça ?
Alors, on est tous coresponsables de ça.
Donc moi, dans le grand débat, c'est la
faute au bon si on prend les chaînes de
valeur, on va dire
le le énergies fossiles, le charbon, le
pétrole, le gaz, il faut bien les
extraire de terre. Et donc le grand
coupable, c'est l'extracteur. Donc là,
on va faire de l'antiextractivisme, on
va dire. il faut euh tirer à boulet
rouge sur
cette cette ce maillon de la chaîne.
Sauf que derrière les autres maillons,
c'est que c'estes ces ressources
minières, elles sont transformées.
Euh transformé. Alors, on va peut-être
dire "Ben non, non, en fait, le vrai
coupable, c'est le gars qui fait la
transformation, c'est le gars qui fait
la raffinerie hein, parce que les
chaînes sont pas toutes intégrées. Donc,
les gens qui font de la mine font pas
forcément tout." Puis après, on va dire
"Ouais, mais attends, non, non, il y a
il y a du transport."
Donc les vrais coupables, c'est c'est
c'est les mecs qui trans qui
transportent. Et après euh Ah ouais,
mais attends, le pétrole en question, si
je prends que le pétrole parce que j'ai
dit il y a charbon, gaz et pétrole. Mais
si je prends le pétrole pour commencer,
je ferai le charbon après. Le pétrole il
sert dans des machines
euh
par exemple des bagnoles pour ou des
avions. Euh ou alors il sertent pour
faire du plastique et alors il ben alors
ou non. C'est peut-être la faute des
gens qui demandent
que ces produits là ça fait parce que on
est quand même tous très content de
pouvoir se déplacer. On aime bien ça. Et
si je comprends un peu la situation sur
l'aérien, il y a un peu de discussion à
gauche à droite mais les gens sont quand
même très très contents de voler. Bon et
parce qu'il considèrent que c'est à
droit et puis en plus c'est des
avantages. Ça fait voir
interdire les vols intérieurs
domestiques.
Pourquoi pas ? Mais ce que je veux dire,
c'est que la la chasse au coupa, moi je
je suis pas câblé comme ça. Je je je
pense vraiment qu'il y a une il y a une
chaîne de responsabilité
et je pense qu'il faut d'abord bien
prendre en considération cette chaîne de
responsabilité pour savoir quelles sont
les actions à mener dans l'ensemble de
la chaîne. Donc
neutraliser la publicité. Est-ce que ça
en fait partie ? Alors, je pense que là,
clairement euh, si on prend les
histoires de voitures et le fait
qu'aujourd'hui euh en France, le SUV euh
s'impose et donc nous fait reperdre euh
une partie de la bataille qu'on avait
commencé à gagner sur les émissions de
gaz FSR li au lié aux lie aux voitures,
là, c'est évident pour moi que la
publicité a un rôle, hein. Je dis pas
que la publicité, c'est le diable absolu
et que du coup craque. Il faut
s'interdire tout ça. Je dis juste la
publicité a un rôle et juste euh il
serait de bon ton de commencer à être un
peu transparent sur le fait que vendre
des SUV ça ça contribue bassivement à
aggraver le problème.
On rajoute quelque chose sur le climat,
on rajoute quelque chose sur les
mesurettes, on rajoute quelque chose
euh Ouais, on va rajouter deux trois
trucs. et que tant que les intérêts des
acteurs sont pas alignés du tout avec
les intérêts de la planète, on va avoir
un problème de fond. Et donc pour faire
cet alignement d'intérêt, il va falloir
qu'on mette en place des dispositifs à
tous les étages qui sont de nature à
faire cet alignement. Donc en gros, moi
si je voulais résumer ma pensée, je
pense que les ceux qui me trouvent qui
me proposent des solutions uniques, j'ai
trouvé la solution magique. Alors par
exemple, vous avez des économistes qui
disent la solution magique c'est la taxe
carbone. On fait une taxe carbone
mondiale
et puis craque, on a résolu le problème.
Je dis ça, vous êtes un tout petit peu
optimiste les enfants. Ça va pas ça va
pas le faire comme ça. Pour quelle
raison ? parce que il faudrait que cette
taxe carbone soit un prix tellement
élevé que on aura des manifes
généralisées dans tous les pays du monde
avant d'y arriver. Donc donc c'est pas
réaliste.
Donc ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire
que de mon point de vue à moi, il faut
effectivement mettre un prix au carbone
pour bien faire comprendre aux uns et
aux autres qu'on peut pas continuer à
mettre des gaz à effet de serre comme si
de rien était. Mais ça veut dire aussi
qu'il faut mettre en place dans tout un
tas de secteurs d'activité
des normes, des règlements pour
cantonner par voie administrative euh un
certain nombre de pollutions. Donc par
exemple dans dans le domaine de la
voiture qu'on a évoqué mais il y a plein
d'autres domaines, il y a des mesures à
prendre. dans le domaine euh du charbon,
on s'en sortira pas tellement autrement
que par des actions assz administratives
assez fortes euh au fur et à mesure de
déclassement de centrale au charbon. Et
puis troisièmement, je crois vraiment
puisque pas
ce qui est en train de se passer, la
Chine fait une politique
d'investissement sur les usines à
charbon qui est
ça se fait ça se fait un tout petit peu.
La la Chine a déclassé toute une série
centrale au charbon les plus
dégueulasses et donc ça se fait
progressivement
et en a remplacé par 10 moins
dégueulasses. C'est ça.
Je je c'est clair qu'en ce moment il y a
il y a encore un problème massif chez
les émergents, mais je voudrais quand
même insister sur un tout petit point,
c'est que
les débats se posent pas de la même
manière et d'ailleurs le rapport au PIB
se pose pas de la même manière selon la
situation socio-économique du pays. sur
le bouton quand on est au Yémen et qu'on
est en train de crever de faim et on est
dans dans la guerre, les problèmes se
posent pas de la même manière que quand
on est un émergent émergé comme la Chine
qui est plus un émergent, qui a un pays
très développé même si il y a encore
beaucoup d'inégalités ou quand on est
les États-Unis ou l'Europe où là le la
question principale de de des Européens,
des Américains c'est d'accepter l'idée
que la consommation matérielle c'est un
peu derrière nous.
Alors, la consommation matérielle, c'est
un peu derrière nous. Donc, ça me permet
de faire un petit petit saut de mouton
sur la finance. la régulation de la
finance, la régulation du capitalisme,
est-ce que ça passe par des choses plus
coercitives comme des investissements
verts, des investissements
Ouais, tu vois, si je peux me permettre
de faire un tout petit euh
Mais permettez-vous
un petit un petit recul historique dans
la question du capitalisme qui nous
occupe là très fondamentalement et qui
va nous occuper pendant quelques
minutes,
on a des une histoire assez longue.
Alors si je va pas reprendre depuis le
début des temps, on va pas la reprendre
depuis le début des temps, mais si on la
reprend tout simplement 19e siècle,
l'idéologie dominante c'est quand même
le scientisme.
Auguste
a une très très grosse foi en la science
croisé avec une idéologie dominante,
c'est que il faut laisser faire, laisser
passer. Donc le le 19e siècle, c'est
c'est une époque de l'économie
occidentale. Je parle pas d'autres pays
pour le moment. On va parler de la la
naissance du capitalisme, enfin le
développement du capitalisme en Europe.
C'est une période où la où les crises
sont permanentes. A y bon mais les
l'idéologie dominante, c'est laisser
passer. Le marché se régule tout seul et
euh le bois mort, les entreprises qui
sont pas bonnes vont vont mourir et puis
ça va redémarrer et cetera et l'offre
fait le fait sa demande et donc tout ça
ça marche très bien. C'est complètement
c'est théorisé, pas mathématiquement
mais c'est théorisé. Bon, arrive
là-dessus la première guerre puis
surtout la crise de 29 et là le retour à
l'équipe ça fait pas du tout. La crise
s'enfonce s'enfonce. Les banques
déposent le bilan et et et le le les
États-Unis connaissent un niveau de
chômage énorme. Cette crise là traverse
l'Europe
et qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Bah, il y a
des contreéactions massives et la guerre
avant la guerre. Euh avant la guerre, on
va parler quand même 2 minutes de ce qui
se passe en Allemagne. Donc des régimes
très autoritaires se mettent en œuvre et
des régimes autoritaires qui se mettent
à raisonner pas du tout selon les les
les codes libéraux. On va dire ça comme
ça pour être simple. Euh l'Allemagne se
s'arme, se réarme à toute vitesse, euh
fait marcher une forme de planche à
billet par les bons de travaux.
Euh c'est bien documenté hein, ça c'est
c'est vraiment clair. Et avant de se
réarmer et créer les les routes, les
autoroutes, le le je suis pas du tout en
train de faire une odde et de féliciter
le tyran qui était au pouvoir. Je suis
juste en train de
surtout surtout les autoroutes, c'était
pour faciliter le passage des blindés.
Pas au début. Au début, il y a plein de
travaux qui sont faits euh
pour fidéliser le peuple,
pour mettre tout le monde au boulot et
ça marche. Et donc euh ce que je veux
dire par là, c'est que cette période là
est un peu euh particulière parce
qu'elle montre qu'une volonté politique
forte permet de sortir d'une crise
majeure. Bon, pendant ce temps-là, le
New Deal avec Roosevelt, c'est aussi une
reprise en main du politiste.
Par de l'endettement, hein, je vous
coupe,
pardon. part de l'endettement.
C'est-à-dire que les Allemands sont
sortis de la crise ou du moins ont
comblé la crise en faisant de
l'endettement.
Les Allemands ont un un marque qui est
très peu euh apprécié à l'extérieur des
frontières allemandes et donc ils font
ce qu'on appelle la des bons de travaux.
Et donc en gros les entrepreneurs
allemands sont payés par des bons de
travaux, donc espèce de planch à billet
interne. Sauf que ces fameux bons de
travaux sont récomptables à la à la
Rebanque et donc ils peuvent valoir
monnaie. Bon, je rentre pas trop dans
les détails. C'était surtout pour dire
que très globalement toute la période
après la crise 29, c'est une période où
les codes et les raisonnements sont très
différents de ceux qu'ils étaient
pendant la période où on croyait
au tout marché et au lafer. Donc on a
cette ce cas qui est qui est qui est
très très
marquant, on va dire ça comme ça. On a
dans la même période les pays
communistes qui fonctionnent pas du tout
sur le libre marché évidemment et on a
Roosevelt aux États-Unis
qui sépare les banques. Euh
le Glastigol Actigola Act qui lance fait
un programme de grands travaux qui remet
une partie de la population américaine
au boulot. Sauf que ça marche pas
complètement parce que il a euh
des une perte de majorité. Les gens
orthodoxes lui reproche de faire du
déficit budgétaire,
il calme son programme et du coup ça se
met à moins bien marcher qu'avant. Et ce
qui sort définitivement la les les
États-Unis de la crise, c'est la
deuxième guerre mondiale et l'industrie
de l'armement qui est d'abord au début
mis en place pour aider l'Angleterre
et donc les alliés et qui ensuite se
démultiplie massivement au moment de
Perlarbourg où là
l'industrie automobile est transformée
pas entièrement mais vraiment fortement
en industrie guerre. Donc là, on a une
une deuxième partie de la et donc ce
cette ce moment de l'histoire fait que
jusqu'aux années 70,
on a des pays soit communistes, soit
kénésiens, dit-on. C'est-à-dire assez
dirigiste. Et on a une période qui est
sur le plan écologique
pas très satisfae.
Bah, les 30 glorieux, c'est c'est
c'était une période où on se continue à
pas du tout s'intéresser
au pen bar. Voilà, c'est ça. C'est open
bar. Bon,
c'est votre génération un petit peu non.
Euh moi, je suis né en 1955. Bon, donc
j'en ai bénéficié. C'est la génération
de mes parents. Puis c'est une
génération de reconstruction. C'est une
génération voilà bon avec des taux de
croissance élevé comme on comme comme
presque comme ce que connaît la Chine
aujourd'hui. Et ce que je veux dire,
c'est que dans les grands les grandes
réflexions de régulation du capitalisme,
cette période là qui est reconnue par
certains comme étant une période, si on
oublie l'écologie que certains font
comme plutôt positive puisqueil y a de
la croissance et donc la croissance
c'est quand même le baromètre de
beaucoup de gens,
bah c'est une période très dirigiste en
fait et donc avec un plan et avec un
système financier qui est ultra
réglementé. On oublie euh tout ça à
partir de du de la de l'arrivée au
pouvoir de Rean et de Sacher. Et là, on
rentre depuis les années 70. Donc là,
c'est l'année où moi je deviens
jeune adulte, on va dire ça comme ça,
dans une période de où où la pensée
dominante devient le libéralisme,
devient le libre échange. Et cette
pensée dominante progressivement
s'impose et y compris dans la
construction européenne et y compris par
la social-démocratie.
Donc l'air de l'or, même l'air mitéran
finalement,
c'est des airs qui sont qui on rentre
dans l'idée que finalement il y a pas
tellement d'alternative le fameux tina
de de Satcher, c'est cette période là et
évidemment c'est accéléré évidemment
rien d'évident mais il se trouve que
c'est accéléré par la chute du mur de
Berlin et l'effondrement de l'empire
soviétique où là le tina c'est bah vous
voyez bien le seul truc qui marche c'est
c'est l'économie de marché le
capitalisme tel qu'il est autres là Ils
se sont plantés. Alors maintenant,
ce qui était largement fou, ils se sont
plantés parce qu'ils ont suivi un
guerre,
une vision
très naïve de de l'histoire. Mais c'est
comme ça que cétait quand même
c'était fait à dessin la vision très
naïve. C'était pour présenter un joli
petit coup pour enfants pour les petits
professeurs d'économie. Ce qui est ce
qui est tout à fait certain, c'est que
les signe tank très libéraux euh les
signes tank,
comment on appelle ça ? des cercles de
pensées.
Des cercles de pensées, c'est ça.
Excusez-moi de cet anglicisme,
des trucs qui servent à rien. Ça sert,
c'est très très é c'est très utile et
très puissant. euh financé à tour de
bras par les les grandes fortunes
américaines, il ils proment imposer une
idéologie,
ils promuvent une une idéologie qui
s'impose. Bon et euh ce qui est assez
curieux, je trouve et assez ironique,
c'est c'est les formes du capitalisme en
Chine
puisque la Chine se met à devenir un
acteur majoritaire et dominant. Et donc
aujourd'hui, on a on a dans le
capitalisme euh un régime très libéral
incarné par les les Américains et un un
régime pas du tout libéral sur le plan
démocratique et sur le plan économique
qui est mixte, qui est très mixte, qui
est le capitalisme chinois et qui est
très puissant. Donc aujourd'hui l'enjeu
de la régulation du capitalisme pour moi
il est extrêmement simple, c'est qu'il y
a pas de théorie qui pourrai nous donner
à penser que faut forcément une école de
marché laisser à elle-même et que c'est
la bonne manière de faire. Je crois
qu'il y a même pas mal d'exemples et pas
mal de preuves et pas mal d'indications
qui disent non c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut faire.
Et si on met les questions d'écologie
et l'anthropocène au cœur du jeu en se
disant "Ouais quand même c'est l'avenir
de milliards d'êtres humains si ce n'est
de l'humanité qui est en jeu aujourd'hui
et qu'on commence à à prendre conscience
et avoir un petit peu peur quoi. Une
petite émotion là sur le fait attention
les climatologues ne disent pas qu'il a
des qu' a des plaisanteries."
On se rend compte que il faut mettre euh
sur la table, remettre sur le métier euh
la grande question du régulation de la
régulation du capitalisme. Et la
régulation du capitalisme, ça consiste
pas à dire je laisse faire la finance,
elle fait ce qu'elle veut, elle est en
train de se verdir et tout va bien,
c'est la fête. Je vous je vous ouvre une
petite parenthèse parce que je vous vois
dans une envolée très optimiste
de régulation du capitalisme.
Euh si on commence à réguler un système
bancaire
hm
qui est déjà tout big to fail
il va se passer quoi ? Il faut le
on prend entièrement contrôle des
banques, on prend entièrement contrôle
sur les salles de marché
non le le non
on ralentit la croissance exponentielle
de certains produits financiers. Oui,
oui, non, pas tout, pas oui, oui et non.
C'est-à-dire pas oui non non, j'ai pas
j'ai Non, non. Si on prend l'exemple de
Roosevelt là qui est quand même assez
typique, il a pas nationalisé le système
bancaire, il a simplement dit "Moi, je
veux euh un système bancaire qui soit
qui sépare les activités." Je dis même
pas, je suis même pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui
ce soit vraiment la solution à supposer
qu'on y arrive parce que les elles sont
elles sont pas que to fail. nos cherbran
sont aussi très attend deux petites
années qu'elles soient un petit peu plus
fatiguées et puis là on pourra leur
mettre un petit glas glace les cas avant
même de parler de de glace stigelax on
peut déjà commencer à se dire il faut
renforcer les fonds propres de manière
un peu substantielle ce qui est pas le
cas
les quoi les balles balles 3 c'est ça
ouais les fonds propres on peut euh
c'est quoi les fonds propres pour
expliquer
oh bah une entreprise comme mon
entreprise à moi qui bon
prenons prenons par exemple la de bank
la de bank bah les les fonds propres
c'est les les capitaux qui qui ont été
mis au départ dans la création de cette
entreprise
auquel s'accumule les réserves,
c'est-à-dire les profits qui ont été
faits les années ultérieur à la création
et qui ont pas été distribué. Donc c'est
ça les capitaux propres. Bon, toute la
question de la régulation et le lien
entre la régulation et l'écologie parce
que ça le cœur de la de la discussion,
c'est du point de vue de la stabilité
financière,
il y a de bonnes raisons de considérer
qu'il est important d'augmenter ces
fameux fonds propres, donc d'obliger les
banques à laisser beaucoup plus d'argent
que
au cas où il y a un pépin.
Au cas où il y a un pépin parce que si
ces fameux fonds propres sont trop
petits, s'il y a un pépin, bah la banque
fait faillite. Alors comme elle fera pas
faillite, c'est nous euh enfin la
Deutsch Bank, ce sera les Allemands
socialisation des pertes
et voilà c'est ça hein qui qui sont ça.
Mais le deuxième truc simultané
de régulation et c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans la période actuelle,
c'est que le deuxième truc simultané
qu'il faut arriver à faire, c'est que
l'orientation du système financier euh
soit telle qu'il cesse de financer le
fameux Brown, c'est-à-dire les activités
désastreuses pour l'environnement. et
qu'il augmente la manière dont il a de
financer les activités dites vertes.
C'est pas c'est pas un peu du green
washing les activités dite vertes ?
Bah non, si on a des m des des
métrologies, des manières de compter qui
sont assez claires. Je redis le
changement climatique, on sait ce que de
quoi il s'agit. On sait que c'est des
gaz à effet de serre. Donc
financier le nucléaire. J'ai pas dit ça.
J'ai dit que que il fallait que les les
il fallait organiser la double
régulation, une régulation concernant la
stabilité financière de sorte que ces
activités financières ne nous pètent pas
à la
vous pouvez vous pouvez vous pouvez. Et
sachant quand même petite parenthèse
dans la parenthèse, je termine, je
termine petite parenthèse dans
parenthèse, c'est que si elle nous pète
à la tronche ces fameuses banque, c'est
très mauvais pour les questions
d'écologie parce que dans la période
2007 2008 2009 où ça a commencé à mal
tourner,
les Grecs ont rasé toutes les forêts.
C'est pas tellement que ça, c'est que
euh les États se retrouvent un
pécuniers. Euh le court terme devient la
priorité absolue de tout le monde parce
qu'il faut euh il faut survivre et donc
tout ce qui est à un horizon un peu plus
long donc typiquement nos sujets passe
complètement à l'asse. Donc euh donc la
la les questions de stabilité financière
sont quand même extrêmement importantes.
Deuxièmement et dans l'autre sens
aujourd'hui les
je mets une parenthèse dans la
parenthèse dans la parenthèse. Vous
parlez de risque financier. Il y avait
il y avait notre
j'arrive même pas à le prononcer notre
Emmanuel Macron qui était à Genève et
qui a alerté sur ce capitalisme qui
allait nous amener le chaos.
Est-ce que vous voulez nous nous délayer
un petit peu le les échelles de de de
menaces que représente le système
financier ? Alors, on va on va essayer
de l'illustrer
euh de manière un peu concrète sans sans
faire voler les milliards euh parce que
les milliards là, ils sont ils volent
par milliers de milliards. Donc
ouais, en trion. En tron. En trion, il
volent en trion. Euh mais sans les sans
les faire voler.
Un trilard, ça fait combien de milliards
? Alors, moi je sais pas ce que c'est
qu'un tri mais un trillon c'est un
millier de milliards. Et donc euh c'est
ces milliers de milliards qui volent
dans les bilans des banques. La la la
BNP par exemple, pour prendre un
exemple, son le total de son bilan c'est
1000 milliards de de d'euros. Le
PIB français,
voilà, à peu près. Mais simplement, elle
a elle manipule beaucoup plus que ça
dans les fameux produits dérivés qui
sont des effets de levier considérables.
Bon, et ça c'est pas dans le bilan mais
ça ça pèse aussi assez lourd. Donc je
juste un tout petit point, c'est que euh
ce qui s'est passé dans la crise de
200829 et ce qui est tout à fait il est
tout à fait concevable que ça se ça se
reproduise dans demain ou dans 6 mois ou
dans 2 ans, c'est des effets de faillite
en cascade. C'est-à-dire que vous avez
tout d'un coup des activités supposées
rentables qui ne le sont plus euh
bah financièrement voilà. Enfin bon,
peut-être que les bilans étaient faux
mais on en sait rien puisque c'est au
débouclement que ça se fait. Et donc à
ce moment-là, comme les banques se
tiennent toutes les unes par la
barbichette des autres, c'est tout le
système qui part en capilotade et c'est
ce qui s'est passé en en 29. Les
entreprises peuvent plus être financées.
Il y a plus cach et voilà, il y a plus
de cash nulle part et tout d'un coup
on a un effondrement du système
financier. Et là évidemment personne
n'aime ça parce que bah
si si ça peut si moi moi j'adore ça.
Ouais ouais.
Quand le VIX s'envole.
Non, il y en a il y en a dans le système
mais il y en a qui spéculent sur sur les
sur ce sur ce genre.
Est-ce que vous avez pris en
considération les créages spéculatifs de
tout ça ou ça représente rien du tout ?
Je ne sais pas moi ce que je sais donc
je répond Non, j'ai pas fait. Ce que je
sais en revanche c'est que on est obligé
en ce moment de s'occuper de cette
question là et de ce risque là. On est
obligé de considérer l'autre risque dans
l'autre sens.
C'est d'ailleurs le fait que la
déstabilisation possible des activités
industrielles qui sont liées au
changement climatique.
Donc si supposons que demain matin on
dise les grandes capitalisations
boursières exon
total pour pas la nommer se mettent à
être imposé de devoir arrêter ce type
d'activité parce qu'on se dit grosso
modo il va falloir quand même cesser
d'extraire
la grande majorité du charbon du pétrole
et du gaz qui a sous terre. Et là, il y
a il y a Total qui rigole.
Et là, il y a un tout petit sujet parce
que tout d'un coup, euh quelque chose
qui valait beaucoup d'argent n'en n'en
vaut plus beaucoup. À ce moment-là,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Bah, ça
déstabilise le système financier.
Et les régulateurs avec qui on discute
quand même un peu régulièrement, les
quoi ? les régulateurs, donc les gens
qui s'occupent de réguler le système
bancaire et financier, donc ils sont par
exemple les gens qui travaillent dans
les banques centrales, ils font ça, ils
font ça très bien.
Ils ont ils ont peur aussi de ce risque
là qui c'est dire attention
on a un risque qui est que ces activité
là si on les arrête trop vite
euh ça crée des des des rumeurs de
marché ça crée des des des des vagues de
difficultés parce que il y a des acteurs
financiers qui ont des portefeuillos de
titre dans lequel s'il se mettent à plus
rien valoir bah la banque se pète la f
c'est pas inextricable.
Non je crois pas.
Et dernier risque de grande prise en
considération depuis quelques années,
c'est dans l'autre sens, si on laisse
faire le changement climatique, à ce
moment-là, on a des activités qui vont
l'assurance
euh non, si on laisse faire le
changement climatique, on va avoir des
dégâts physiques et matériels sur tout
un tas d'entreprises qui donc
elles-mêmes vont se mettre à plus rien
valoir du tout parce que elles seront
impactées par ces fameux désordres. Et
jusqu'à présent euh ces dégâts là
étaient considérés comme étant très très
loin et tout d'un coup, on se dit "Ah
bah c'est pas si clair que ça hein, il y
a des entreprises
notamment des entreprises européennes
euh qui ont des ennuis très très sérieux
au Texas du fait de d'incident
climatique un peu grave. Donc
aujourd'hui, le système financier, il
est au carrefour de trois grandes crises
possibles qui sont la crise intrinsèque
de l'instabilité financière, la crise
qui serait on va très vite dans la
transition pour pour euh atteindre nos
objectifs 1 degr 5 ou 2 degrés où on
laisse traîner le truc mais là c'est les
incidents climatiques qui commencent à
arriver. Donc moi, mon sentiment très
fort, c'est que ce petit milieul qui
était totalement indifférent à ce sujet,
il y a
on va on va le chiffrer, on va dater
avant 2014,
t passe, ça fait 5 ans, commence à se à
se dire "Ou là là, faut vite se mettre
autour de la table pour commencer à
discuter de ça." C'est là où on en est.
Alors que le GC a a attiré notre
attention sur c tous ces sujets là il y
a quelques décennies.
Club de Rome,
le club de Rome sur climat, ils étaient
pas très précis.
Le club de Rome et et par ailleurs, moi
j'ai beaucoup les travaux du club de
Rome parce qu'il cit c'est vraiment très
innovant. C'est la première fois qu'on a
des travaux systémiques euh qui permet
de de mettre sur la table toute une
série de problèmes qui sont les
ressources, la pollution, la régulation
globale. Euh mais à l'époque ça avait
pas ça avait pas valeur de solidité
scientifique comme ce que peut avoir
comme valeur de solidité scientifique
les rapports avec les Lugc. On était en
train de vulgariser les les trillions de
trilliards de milliards.
Ça représente quoi ? Faites-nous une
petite métaphore autour de ça.
Euh
est-ce que bancaire ?
C'est pas facile à C'est pas facile à
Je sais pas faire ça. Je sais pas faire.
Je je je sais pas comment représenter
des billets de milliards. Déjà un
milliard, je trouve c'est compliqué sauf
pour les milliardaires. Mier milliard,
je sais pas répondre.
On va on va on va se réouvrir une petite
parenthèse.
Le le monde politique
est bien conscient de ça. Non, ils sont
quand même bien informés. vous les
informez correctement, ils ont des
services qui les informment sur le
risque bancaire, le risque climatique.
Bon, pour être tout à fait trivial, ils
arrivent en partie niveau 12 tout de
suite. Ils ont un système financière qui
est un système financier qui est très
précaire dans qui évolue dans un système
overstretch hyper tendu sur tout un taxe
facteur. Est-ce que vous pensez qu'on a
un système politique qui a les épaules
pour faire cette transition là ou
simplement on continue de discuter sympa
?
le système financier va se réguler
auprès des régulateurs des banques
centrales. Les agences de notation vont
continuer leur petit manège, tout va
bien se passer et puis euh on va
enterrer votre génération.
Oui. OK. D'accord.
Et puis on commencera à faire le boulot
ou
c'est gentil. La la probabilité que les
choses se passent tout seul et très bien
est faible.
Euh elle est faible parce que si je
prends l'Europe euh qui est un système
politique euh qui a une bonne
sensibilité, je parle pas des on va dire
en non pardon, je m'excris mal, le
système politique est est
est assis sur une région du monde a 500
millions de personnes qui ont une
sensibilité aux questions
d'environnement, on va dire ça comme ça,
qui qui n'est pas nulle et qui a un
rapport à l'espace qui ou à l'infini qui
est pas du tout le rapport américain
australien. Ce qui est très très
étonnant dans le système dans les
représentations culturelles américaine
ou australienne, c'est c'est des
représentations de l'infini. C'est pas
tout à fait par hasard que les le
transhumanisme et toutes toutes les les
idéologies qui qui visent à nous dire
"Mais il y a pas de limite si la
technologie vont nous sauver."
Oui, ça c'est c'est pas étonnant qu'elle
qu'elle se développe dans des dans des
régions du monde de grandiosité si j'ose
ce terme. L'Europe n'est pas le cas.
L'Europe, c'est des d'abord c'est des
régions qui ont connu des guerres. Euh
c'est des c'est des pays où la
concentration euh est pas par pas celle
de la de la Chine. Enfin, elle est quand
même assez forte. Les espaces sont
limités, on n'a pas ce sentiment
d'infini. Bon, malheureusement, le
système politique européen, il est il
est cafté sur des dogmes et sur des
considération euh qui s'impose aux uns
et aux autres euh qui empêche euh
massivement euh de donner un élan rapide
et et et à la hauteur des des des défis.
Ça ça me paraît vraiment assez clair. On
a on a beaucoup moi j'insiste beaucoup
sur sur cette sur cette affaire de de
dogmatisme parce que je je pense
vraiment que le blocage banque central,
déficit budgétaires, pact de stabilité
de croissance, tout tous ces mécanismes
là sont sont complètement euh
intriqués
intriqués et
crée des résistances et de la de la
d'une viscosité considérable face à à
alors qu'il faudrait prendre des mesures
rapides.
Il y a il y a quand même un avantage,
non pas à ce système dogmatique dont on
pourrait reparler 2 minutes tout à
l'heure, mais à la question démocratique
en Europe. Ça c'est quand même un
avantage, c'est que le temps de la de
l'élaboration commune est quand même un
temps important. Ce qu'on a v on a vu
tout à l'heure, moi je crois, si je
reprends un peu mon avis sur les sur les
histoires de gilets jaunes, que le
problème massif qui a eu ce pouvoir là,
c'est son c'est son manque complet de
crédibilité et de sincérité. euh sur la
question climatique. Donc on n'a pas cru
du tout le président de la République,
on n'a pas cru son premier ministre
quand il nous disait "On on est euh on
on s'occupe de la question climatique et
d'ailleurs on va mettre en place une
taxe carbone pour cette affaire-là. Les
gens l'ont pas cru du tout euh parce que
l'ensemble des dispositifs qu'il faut
mettre en place si on veut être sérieux
dans la lutte concha climatique se
résume pas du tout à la tasse carbone.
On en a élaboré quelques quelques
petites touches là depuis qu'on qu'on
parle ensemble mais je pense qu'il y a
il y a vraiment ce problème là. Et donc
de mon point de vue à moi, l'avantage
européen, c'est la capacité euh de
discuter euh collectivement
pour pour prendre collectivement
ensemble la mesure euh du défi à à
relever pour prendre collectivement
ensemble la mesure du fait que c'est pas
avec les outils euh préanthropocènes et
avec les modes de raisonnement
préanthropocène qu'on va régler le
problème qui est posé par la question de
l'anthropocène et je Moi, je suis pas du
tout à l'aise avec l'idée que la
solution c'est en gros une dictature
verte, on va comme il y a urgence
craque,
on va installer un pouvoir fort qui va
qui va régler le problème. Je suis pas à
l'aise avec ça. Je je al pour une raison
assez simple et assez évidente,
ça risque de se faire tout seul. Non
non, je crois pas. J'aurais même
développé l'argument. Si
les fondamentaux de société se cassent
la gueule, que j'écologise des gueules,
on va avoir quoi ? Des des gouvernements
un peu plus fermes, non ? Oui, je
voudrais quand même je voudrais quand
même avancer l'argument pour lequel je
crois pas à cette affaire de de
dictature verte ou de ou de despot
éclairé. C'est mesures coerciitives pour
les pour
non de despot éclairé c'est il y aura
des mesures clé
les sont toujours éclairés hein.
Ouais ouais enf c'est ce qu'ils disent.
Euh enfin en tout cas ce qui est clair
je vais l'argument est assez simple
c'est à Martiè qu'il a développé cet
argument c'est dire les pays où il y
avait le plus de famines dans toute
l'histoire qu'il a regardé lui en détail
c'est précisément des pays de dictature
parce que le dictateur a aucune raison
de laisser passer l'information. Donc
les gens crevaient de faim dans les
coins, ça savait pas puisque la
formation circule pas. Donc je je suis
très très sûr
que malheureusement ou heureusement,
j'en sais rien mais malheureusement il
va y avoir des dégâts
donc
sur la démocratie.
Non non non, il va y avoir des dégâts
sur les gens sur les vrais gens. Et les
dégâts sur les vrais gens dans une
démocratie, ça appelle euh la résolution
du problème. Dans une non démocratie,
les dégâts sur les vrais gens, tout le
monde s'en fout parce qu'il y a un un
chef au pouvoir qui se fout des dégâts
sur les vrais gens puisque de toute
façon, il a pas besoin des vrais gens
pour être réélu.
Donc je j'insiste un peu parce que le le
le le le disposition les dispositifs
démocratiques qui sont lents et qui nous
ralentissent dans la dans la vie qu'on
l'envie qu'on aurait on aurait de
traiter le problème, ils ont quand même
cet avantage là, c'est d'avoir toujours
cette capacité de de faire des cordes de
rappel parce que si on prend des mesures
un peu raides, il faudra prendre des
mesures un peu raides. Je dis on c'est
les gens qui sont
notre génération.
Non, nous nous là les uns et les autres
les les mesures impores vont être
prises. Il y a absolument besoin d'un
d'un contrôle démocratique et d'un
retour d'information pour pour être sûr
qu'on va dans le bon sens, qu'on se
trompe pas. Et ce retour d'information,
il suppose des libertés.
Il suppose qu'on soit capable nous
encore de se parler, que moi j'ai encore
le droit de d'exprimer ce que j'ai envie
de dire, mais moi, vous les autres, de
manière à ce que la formation circule.
C'est important parce que la tendance
naturelle des gens qui voient le niveau
de stress augmenter et qui voit
l'ampleur des défis, ça va être de dire
bon allez on arrête de discuter
maintenant. Moi, je vous dis que la
solution c'est ça, ça ça ça je pense que
ça marchera pas. Donc donc du coup ce à
quoi je crois moi pour revenir à la
vision très globale et très systémique,
c'est une réunionité aigue,
c'est que euh grand je reprends euh les
dispositions qu'il faut mettre en place
pour y arriver sont des dispositions qui
touchent l'ensemble des acteurs puisque
j'ai dit tout à l'heure
cherchons pas les coupables et on est
tous coresponsables de ce bazar là. Bon,
donc l'ensemble des acteurs, la finance,
euh les états, les collectivités
territoriales, les entreprises, les
ménages,
tout toutes ces tous ces groupes
d'intérêt là, on va dire ça comme ça,
sont doivent entrer en mouvement chacun
avec des des actions spécifiques et
différentes et avec chacun des euh
devant recevoir
ça été modélisé ça ou ça reste un appel
ou quelque chose ?
C'est impossible à modéliser de manière
précise. C'est c'est quoi ? chercher un
consensus.
Non, c'est pas des consensus, c'est
c'est c'est Non non non, je je vais être
plus concret pour qu'on
Je me fais l'avocat du diable, j'essaie
de vous ti un peu.
Non, mais vous avez raison, je vais
essayer d'être d'être de prendre bien un
exemple
factuel concret. Voilà. Non, mais on va
dire ça, on va dire. Bon, nous on fait
des petits travaux là chez chez Carbon 4
actuellement pour se dire si supposons
qu'un ménage motivé euh veuille réduire
son empreinte carbone
au Purkina Faso
en France. Qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? il
réduit sa consommation de viande rouge
parce que le parce que consommer la
viande rouge, c'est avoir fait vivre une
un rominant qui va émettre une métade.
Moi je réduis fortement alors moi je je
suis ce qu'on appelle flexitarien, c'est
je réduis fortement ma conservation de
viande rouge. Bon on va dire prendre les
moyens de transport les plus les moins
émetteurs de gaz à effet de serre. Donc
là, je vais un pied, moi je suis facile
parisien
et ainsi de suite. Ça veut dire réduire
les les températures de consign et
cetera. Bon, faire ça, ça permet de
réduire un peu son empreinte de carbone,
mettons que ça permet de la réduire de
20 %.
Or pour être neutre carbone, c'est pour
arriver en 2050 à aux objectifs qui sont
les nôtres, c'est-à-dire la
zéro émission nette neutralité carbone,
il faut diviser au moins par 5 notre ou
6 ou 7 notre empreinte de carbone. Ça
veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire que il va
falloir jouer sur des leviers sur
lequels le la pure vertu ou ou la la
pure envie de bien faire ne fonctionne
pas. Bon, qu'est-ce qui émet du CO2 ?
C'est nos machines, c'est nos
équipements, c'est les usines dans
lequelles ces machines équipements sont
fabriquées. C'est ça qui é du CO2. Donc
là, on voit bien et c'est
l'organisation, c'est le fait que je si
je suis à 30 km de Carpentra dans une
maison mal isolée qui échauffe au
fioule, je peux être vertueux. Je suis
quand même très embêté pour régler ce
problème là. Donc qu'est-ce qu'il va
falloir que je fasse ? C'est tricoter
des pulls.
C'est ça, mon ami. Et donc, il va
falloir un jour que je pense à changer
de de chaudière au ful. Euh, il va
falloir que je me dise "Bah, ma maison,
est-ce qu'il faut pas que je l'isole ?"
Donc, il va falloir dépenser de
l'argent, ce qu'on appelle investir. Et
il va falloir que les collectivités
territoriales investissent. Il va
falloir que les collectivités
territoriales investissent dans des
transports en commun, moins émetteur de
gaz effet de serre. Il va falloir que
les industries et les industriels
émettent euh investissent pour faire des
dispositifs et des des des machines qui
émettent moins de CO2. Donc, prenons
l'exemple de la voiture, ça veut dire
passer des motorisations actuelles qui
sont très émétrices de CO2 puisque les
bagnoles ça roule principalement au fiel
actuellement un tout petit peu au gaz
enfin comme en France c'est
essentiellement du FU.
faire des voitures qui qui sont soit
électriques, soit hydrogènes, je sais
pas quelle la solution technologique qui
va l'emporter à terme tout ça ça demande
beaucoup d'investissement chez les
industriels. Donc la les mouvements
d'ensemble et le mouvement d'ensemble
qui va vouloir faire c'est acteur
catégorie d'acteur par catégorie
d'acteur créer des incitation
ou des interdictions ou des règlements
on y arrive
qui sont de nature à ce que cet acteur
là progressivement sa fameuse empreinte
carbone elle baisse parce qu'il faut
interdire les fraises en hiver.
Ah je crois pas que ce soit la bonne
solution.
Je crois pas. Je je il y a il y a des
secteurs Non non mais il y a des il y a
des secteurs ou des ou des quatre figu
où l'interdiction fonctionne très bien.
Si je prends un exemple très concret euh
il y a un produit qui est très émetteur
de qui est très réchauffant dont le
pouvoir de réchauffement est très élevé.
Le méthane
non c'est les HFC donc c'est les
hydroflucarbone c'est les produits qui
sont dans les
dans les frigos. Bon
les acteurs de type grande distribution.
Je vais pas faire la publicité pour les
marques.
On fait pas de pub pour les marques.
Oh donc les grands les grands
distributeurs mondiaux
peuvent investir massivement aujourd'hui
pour sortir de leur frigo dans lequel on
va se servir du congé là. Tous ces
dispositifs qui sont à base de gaz
fleuré peuvent ils peuvent le faire
aujourd'hui. Il y a toutes les solutions
techniques.
Ils ont peut-être pas envie.
Bah écoutez là justement sur ce terrainl
la question de l'envie se pose pas à mon
avis. qu'on les taxe. Non, là c'est
beaucoup plus radical. On annonce d'ors
et déjà que ce sera interdit. Basta.
Donc là, il y a des cas de figur c'est
la même c'est en gros la même histoire
que que le la couche de l'ozone. La
couche de l'ozone, c'était des produits,
c'était des CC. Le trou de le contraire,
le trou de l'ozone pardon, c'était des
produits de ce type, c'était des fluurés
qui avaient par mécanisme chimique dans
l'atmosphère, ils avaient l'inconvénient
de faire ce fameux trou. Là la taxe tout
ça marche pas. C'est bouff j'interdit
mais simplement je d'accord sur un
calendrier
parce que
comme le glyphosate
voilà un peu voilà un peu comme ça. Bon
donc il y a des cas de figur
mais le glyphosate c'est pas un bon
exemple
non mais on va on va rester sur le
climat de ministre donc il y a des cas
de figure où la bonne solution
collective c'est l'interdiction pure et
dure. Il y a des cas de figure je vais
prendre des cas un peu plus engageants.
Euh dans le domaine de la voiture, faut
dire faut annoncer une date
ou le Brexit,
on annonce une date, mettons 2035 2040,
bon, on annonce une date, on dit à
partir climatique.
Non, non, non, on annonce que il y aura
euh on aura plus le droit de
commercialiser des voitures de de avec
des des équipements qui émettent du CO2.
Bon,
euh, prenons un autre exemple très
concret. dans le domaine du logement, il
y a encore 4 millions euh de chaudias au
fiou euh en France, 4 millions de
logements, il faut annoncer tout
simplement que à partir de telle date
terminée. Donc il y a des donc le
mélange alors les les économistes, ils
appellent ça le polysimique, c'est un
truc très vilain en anglais, mais le
mélange de politique publique qu'il faut
faire pour résoudre notre problème, il
est pas inaccessible. Je je redis, je
crois pas qu'il s'agisse d'installer un
pouvoir autoritaire pour les raisons que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure qui me
paraissent très très fondamental.
De je crois pas à une solution unique de
type on met une grande taxe carbone et
ça règle tout le problème. Je crois pas
à un instant. 3 Je pense qu'il faut
attaquer les sujets euh secteur par
secteur et acteur par acteur. Bon et
donc pour venir à finit pas un blitz cck
un blck sur l'écologie.
Je crois pas non. Et je crois pas parce
que ça marchera pas. Et donc je je moi
je suis trop convaincu de la nécessité
de pas échouer pour pour prendre des
paris. Euh dit je tente comme ça puis on
verra bien. Bah non, on verra pas bien.
Non. Et donc je je reviens à un point
clé, c'est que euh pour faire ça euh et
je reviens à ce que je disais sur
l'Europe, il faut impérativement que les
dispositifs européens cessent de nous
bloquer euh dans une idéologie
totalement mortifère dans laquelle pour
des raisons qui sont qui datent des
années 80 parce que des ces fameux
traités européens, ils ont été fabriqués
et je redis he la c'est pas un problème
politique gauche- droite puisque la
social-démocratie a été très
coresponsable de de ce trucl- là hein.
Euh donc c'est pas c'est pas la droite
qui a imposé un système que la la gauche
aurait pas aurait pas appréciéement. Et
dans ce système l'obsession
c'était réduire la place de du secteur
public puisqueen fait on sortait de 30
40 ans
de gab
enfin de de belles périodes de 30
glorieuses considéré comme étant non pas
de la GABG mais du dirigime excessif de
l'empêcher de faire et cetera. Bon, donc
il y a
c'est votre génération de 68 qui a qui a
qui a décré décrété ça comme ça.
Bon et donc euh cette période là où on a
fabriquer les traités européens, elle a
été fabriquée dans un dans un mode de
raisonnement de ce genre. C'est aussi
pour ça qu'on a créé une banque centrale
indépendante en Europe. C'est à la fois
parce que les Allemands étaient
demandaient, mais c'était aussi parce
que l'idée c'était il y a un risque
inflationniste permanent. Si l'état la
planche à billet, il va nous fabriquer
de l'inflation et l'inflation, c'est
très mal. Ça c'était la pensée des
années 80 90. Bon, donc je pense que
c'est gravissime pour nos pour nos
questions à nous parce que évidemment
dans tout ce que je viens de dire euh
j'ai besoin d'un état qui soit pas du
tout un état dictatorial ni un état qui
soit qui impose une vision euh de
manière verticale. J'ai pas besoin d'un
état vertical, mais j'ai quand même
besoin d'un état et de collectivité
territoriale qui ont des ressources, des
moyens qui sont revalorisés dans l'idée
que euh alors si on emploie un vrai gros
mot, euh c'est pas trop idiot de
planifier
euh le passage d'une économie
totalement carbonée à une économie 1
décarbonée 2 qui respecte la vie et la
biité. Donc planifier, ça consiste pas à
prendre sa calculette ou son tableur
Excel pour dire tout ce qu'on va faire
dans les dans les 20 ans millimèt par
par millimè. Mais ça veut dire voilà le
cadre, le cap dans lequel on va
permettre de transformer l'économie de
là où elle est vers là où on veut. Donc
là, il y a aucun groupe de travail qui
fait ça auprès des télé. Aujourd'hui, le
il y a des c'est un peu éparce
de de ce que je vois et il y a des
tentatives, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a euh
la cour des comptes européennes dit il
faut 1100 milliards par an
d'investissement dans les
infrastructures pour réussir le pari de
la transformation d'économie en carmone.
Il y a un sing tank en France qui
s'appelle I force qui I4CE en français
ex CDC climat qui fait pas mal de calcul
pour dire il manque plusieurs dizaines
de milliards par an au rendez-vous. Si
on veut simplement suivre des
trajectoires, il y a en France termine,
il y a en France un truc qui s'appelle
la stratégie nationale bacarbone.
Ça existe ça donc ça existe. Sauf ce que
c'est fait dans un silo dans un coin et
c'est pas du tout un projet de société.
Quand quand Nicolas Hul démissionne du
gouvernement, on dit pour résumer
trivialement en gros ils vont pas faire
grand-chose. Donc bon, je vais voir
ailleurs.
On en est pas un peu là.
On a un système inextricable avec une
inertie gigantesque
interconnecté à l'échelle mondiale et on
prend un exemple très concret en France.
C'est Ouais, je réponds tout de suite.
C'est inextricable sauf que et j'adore
pas du tout monsieur Trump. Vraiment,
j'adore
pourtant vous avez dit dans une
interview que Trump était pas une
interview mais une conférence c'était
une boutade je pense. Euh Trump c'était
une obè.
Ouais mais c'était pour une autre
raison. Et le fait de dire que c'était
inobè, c'est qu'il a fait bouger des
choses. Et je reviens sur ce que je veux
dire là et puis là, j'ai le temps de
développer en une minute, c'est que
monsieur Trump
face à un truc qui était le dogme
absolu, le libre échange mondial.
Bah, il a dit bah non quoi non c'est pas
un dogme quoi. Moi moi je voilà quoi.
Donc je dis pas c'est un modèle, je dis
juste
retour au protectionnisme mécanisme tout
à fait précis. c'est je dis juste il a
pas considéré que ce trucl s'imposait à
lui de manière es cathédra parce que
c'était une vérité révélée. Bon
aujourd'hui si je prends l'exemple de la
question climatique évidemment qu'on a
besoin aussi
d'éviter ce qu'on appelle les les fuites
carbone c'est-à-dire vous avez une
région du monde qui est ultra vertueuse
qui a qui fait plein d'interdictions
qui exporte sa pollution
voilà mais qui exorte sa pollution c'est
ça l'idée quoi. Bah pour éviter ça, en
gros, il faut se redire tiens mettons
mettons des tarifs euh et des
protections de bananières basta. Donc on
peut appeler ça protectionner surveux.
Bon bah ça met complètement indifférent.
C'est pas une question de sémantique. Là
c'est une question juste de se dire
aujourd'hui euh la remise en cause des
dogmes, elle doit être automatique.
C'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui, si je peux
dire un truc un peu fort, ça consiste à
dire
quand on me dit ça c'est comme ça, je
dis "Ah bon ? Pourquoi c'est comme ça ?
Jean-Marc Geor Kovici qu'on a cité tout
à l'heure quand il a raison de rappeler
la physique. Donc la physique s'impose à
nous mais les conventions de théorie
économique elles s'impose pas du tout
comme de la physique. Donc on a
considéré pendant très longtemps que le
libre échange était la bonne solution
pour plein de raisons. Si aujourd'hui on
se dit bah non, le libre échange c'est
c'est pas quelque chose qui permet de
sortir de la crise climatique parce que
les régions du monde qui vont
être très performant sur le truc
carbone, elles peuvent ne pas être
performantes du point de vue
traditionnel ce que je parlais tout à
l'heure de de non comptabilité puisqueen
fait le gr le libre échange c'est un
truc de comptabilité à comptabilité et
ben ça veut dire qu'on remet en cause le
libre échange. Point barre. Si moi je
dis il faut faire un effort de guerre
euh au niveau européen euh donc un plan
marchal euh pour rénover les bâtiments,
les rénover les logements, euh pour euh
transformer euh l'industrie automobile
euh en évitant que ça profite
exclusivement euh à nos amis euh
Chinois, coréens ou japonais
qu'on viennent pas m'expliquer que c'est
pas possible parce que il y a des
conventions budgétaires et comptables
qui sont là et qui s'imposent à nous
comme de toute éternité comme la
physique s'impose parce que la physique
s'impose. Donc c'est ça qu'il faut à mon
avis remettre en cause et le caractère
inextricable, je c'est un peu un
argumentina, c'est-à-dire on se dit "Ah
c'est compliqué, la vie est compliquée,
donc on s'en sortira jamais. Euh bah je
vois pas pourquoi donc il y a pas de
raison.
On est peut-être un peu tous dans le
déni
Ah, vous voulez dire que je suis un peu
dans le déni ?
Non, j'ai juste dit que vous étiez
économiste, mais bon.
Je prends un exemple concret. En face de
de nos côtes, on a balancé les stocks de
d'armes chimiques pendant des décennies.
Euh ça se sait, on est tous au courant,
du moins ceux qui s'intéressent un peu
au sujet. On a des stocks gigantesques
dans la manche en face de nos côtes.
C'est en train d'être corrodé. Ça va
dégueuler partout. Ça va anéantir toute
la faune et la flore dans la Manche
pendant des des centaines d'années. Mais
on s'en fout he un, il y a personne qui
qui personne n'entraite. Il y a
personne. Ils sont tous dans
l'incantation autour de de ces sujets là
mais personne ne bouge.
Ouais. Ouais. Oui. Peut-être. Mais si je
prends d'autres exemples, on pour on va
toujours argumenter.
Je prends la question du plastique. La
question du plastique c'est qui une
question qui est à la mode en ce moment.
Pourquoi elle est à la mode ? parce que
il y a eu des actions très très
permanentes, très continues et très
efficaces de sensibilisation par les
réseaux en fait he les réseaux internet
et les réseaux associatifs qui se sont
bagarrés là-dessus. Euh on est encore
jusqu'à présent dans l'incantation
euh mais le passage de je suis dans
l'incantation je fais quelque chose, il
peut aller plus vite qu'on croit. Si je
prends un exemple très concret pour
illustrier, vous allez trouver optimiste
une fois de plus, mais je je persiste.
Euh moi, j'étais en Italie euh le jour
où le la loi sur le tabac est passée.
C'était quand même très frappant. Euh du
jour au lendemain euh on avait plus le
droit de fumer dans les tabacs, dans les
lieux publics. Ça s'est fait du jour au
lendemain. Vous auriez fait une
prévision 5 ans avant sur est-ce que ce
type de mesure qui est quand même une
mesure d'interdiction pur et dure euh
peut passer euh en Italie ? Réponse
sûrement pas quoi. Et en fait le truc
est passé. Donc il y a quand même des
effets de maturité, des effets de
maturation. Donc euh sur le cas précis
de la de de vos fus chimiques, je
connais pas le dossier donc j'ai rien à
dire mais je vois bien des cas où où la
la
prise de conscience se se fait comme ça
pouf de manière il y a une espèce de
phénomène de cristallisation. Si je
prends un exemple évident qui est la
question de de des poumons et de la de
la survie de nos en bonne santé de nos
enfants et de nous-mêmes dans les villes
qui sont asphyxiés par les par les par
les poussières, par les microparticules,
c'est le jour et la nuit par rapport à
moi euh ce que j'entendais, ce que je
voyais, ce que je percevais de la
compréhension sociale de ce sujet il y a
même pas 5 ans. Donc
à mon avis hein, le raisonnement qui
consiste à dire on est dans
l'incantation, il se passera rien et
donc forcément tout ça ça va aller dans
le mur. C'est un raisonnement qui est
qui consiste simplement à projeter de
manière homogène tout un tas de
comportements comme s'il se passait rien
du tout.
Vous connaissiez vous connaissez
Aurélien Barreau ?
Je le connais pas personnellement.
Vous connaissez ses ses théories, ses
prospectives, son prisme de lecture ?
Je pas pas spécialement.
Et non pour savoir si vous le jugez
comme un gourou dictatorial
vert, un cmer vert. Non non, ce que je
vois parce que je connais pas assez
bien, ce que je vois c'est qu'il y a
évidemment toute une série de d'auteurs
et de de de penseurs qui qui disent qui
affirment très fort qu'il faut prendre
des mesures fortes et radicales sur tous
les plans de la vie parce que c'est la
seule manière de euh et donc en gros
l'argument je pense mais je comme comme
je n'ai pas discuté avec lui, je sais
pas exactement si je déforme pas, je
pense que l'argument c'est de dire si on
ne fait pas prendre conscience
à l'opinion publique, à chacun d'entre
nous de l'intensité de l'effort qu'il va
falloir à faire. On risque pas d'y
arriver quelque part.
Il faut que nos politiques nous montrent
le chemin. Je je suis pas complètement
d'accord avec ça.
C'estàd qu'il faut il faut les laisser
continuer le jet privé pour faire sans
born des choses comme ça.
Non, vous avez raison de dire que euh
il y a des valeurs d'exemplarité. Donc
là où moi je pense que la valeur
d'exemplarité était très frappante,
c'est par exemple à Davos quand la
missberg a dit "Mais attendez, ils
arrivent tous en jet et ça ça va pas."
Greta là, elle a raison parce que c'est
clair que c'est très très choquant. Euh
mais moi, pour moi, la valeur
d'exemplarité, c'est plus fort que ça.
C'est-à-dire que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure, il y a les États, les
collectivités, les entreprises et les
ménages. Je prends un exemple très très
simple et très très concret. On a
vraiment besoin que les écoles dans
laquelle il y a nos enfants, la
nourriture soit de bonne qualité et que
le goût soit restauré et que donc oui,
ça coûte cher mais c'est de mon débat
budgétaire, on en parlera peut-être
après si on a le temps. Et et
deuxièmement,
on a besoin que les gamins arrivent dans
des écoles qui où le mode de de
régulation de la température soit pas,
j'ouvre les fenêtres parce qu'il fait
une température insupportable, parce que
j'ai pas de thermostat, parce que j'ai
un chauffage qui est complètement
délabré et parce que j'ai mes mes écoles
sont sont des sont des passoirs
thermiques. Donc la valeur d'exemplarité
pour moi c'est c'est numéro 1. Le
patrimoine public et ce qui est sous la
responsabilité très opérationnel de
l'état des collectivités territoriales.
Je pense que c'est très important
que là il y ait des mesures urgentes qui
soient prises. Et je reviens à mon
obsession budgétaire parce que ceci
coûte quelques dizaines de milliards
d'euros par an en France. Et si on est à
l'échelle européen, on parle plutôt de
quelques centaines de milliards d'euros
par an. Et donc, je suis très persuadé
de
que qu'il va falloir annoncer haut et
fort qu'on a de nouveaux arbitrages à
faire. Alors, les économistes de dont je
fais partie disent il faut il va falloir
faire des arbitrages en faveur de
l'investissement
et en défaveur de la consommation. hein,
c'estàd il va falloir que les uns et les
autres, on commence à comprendre qu'il y
a besoin d'investir au sens et pour les
raisons que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
qu'il faut il faut que nos
infrastructures, il faut que nos
équipements, il faut que nos machines
deviennent propres et mettent moins de
CO2. Et du coup en contrepartie, très
probablement, il va falloir qu'on
consomme moins parce que on gaspie à
tour de bras et puis l'argent est quand
même pas infini. Donc il va bien falloir
faire un peu d'équilibre. Euh à très
court terme
euh euh la partie publique de ce
programme là est importante
pour les questions d'exemplarité que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure. Et
deuxièmement, elle a un deuxième elle a
une deuxième grosse importance, c'est
que il y a des actions qui seraient à la
main des acteurs privés, que ce soit les
entreprises ou les ménages ou même des
financiers, on en parlera encore tout à
l'heure, mais que ces acteurs-là ne
feront pas parce que il les considèrent
comme insuffisamment rentable. Donc euh
quelle est l'incitation qu'a aujourd'hui
un ménage à rénover son logement ? il va
mettre 20000 balles sur la table pour
gagner euh
20000 pour récupérer ses 20000 balles
dans 30 ans.
Voilà, c'est ça. Bon, il le fera pas.
Donc donc je pense qu'il faut sortir de
là, pas faire de la rénovation
énergétique, un totem absolu, mais se
dire il va falloir quand même inciter et
aider euh
le système. Donc donc je maintiens, je
persiste et je signe. aujourd'hui par
rapport au au 40 ou 50 ans de
représentation collective que finalement
le marché c'est vachement bien et que
les années d'avant c'était vraiment
moins bien parce qu'on était dans une
économie dirigée, je pense qu'il faut
tourner cette page et rentrer dans une
nouvelle histoire dans laquelle on dit
on a besoin
de vision, on a besoin de cap et ça
tombe bien parce que en fait on a besoin
de long terme, on a besoin d'un projet
de société
et évidemment euh pour Pour que ça ce
soit crédible, porté et que ça
fonctionne, il faut
un gouvernement qui l'incarne
et qui soit élu sur la base de quelque
chose qui qui correspond à ça. Donc
petit coup de chance, il semblerait
qu'au niveau européen, on ait un
mouvement électoral qui aille plutôt
dans le sens que je raconte.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a l'impression et
j'espère que c'est pas un feu de un feu
un feu de paille que euh les jeunes se
rendent compte que ils ont une
responsabilité non pas de sauver le
monde mais d'aller voter et que ça crée
des nouveaux équipes politiques qui font
qu'on on peut bien espérer avoir ce que
je dis là, c'est-à-dire la capacité de
construire collectivement un projet de
société dans lequel ce que je dis là est
pris au sérieux et du coup ça ça permet
de se décliner et je reviens parce que
je le redis à la fois sur la remise en
cause de ces fameux dogmes budgétaire
on n pas encore parlé de la dette
publique mais de tout ce qui tourne
autour de ces de ce de ce trucl à la
fois ça doit remettre en cause dans les
discussions avec le patronat
et en particulier avec le MEDF et les
organisations représentatives
le le dogme du commerce international du
living du level playing field l'idée que
finalement le monde se porte beaucoup
mieux si les règles du jeu sont les plus
basses possibles et les bonnes pour tout
le monde. Et ça remet en cause
euh l'idée que on s'en sortira sans en
simplifiant tout et enlevant normes et
règlements qui sont des empêcheurs de
tourner rond. Non non, c'est pas comme
ça que ça se passe. Il faut remettre en
cause le libre échange au niveau
mondial. Euh il faut on a besoin d'un
d'un état et d'une puissance publique
qui annonce la croître en cause le libre
échange à l'état mondial. On est en
pleine guerre économique,
les Chinois sont un couteau tiré, les
Américains sont un couteau tiré.
Ça se fait en guerre économique. Bah
je ce que je disais tout à l'heure, la
bonne nouvelle de l'histoire c'est que
le dogme est
foutu en l'air clairement.
Donc si l'Europe
et les élites européennes se mettent à
se
à à atterrir, elles vont bien voir que
évidemment qu'il faut le mettre en
cause,
il faut pas faire comme ça. Faut faire
parce que on n pas l'impression qu'ils
atterrissent quand mme ils se gratent
beaucoup le nez, non ?
Question internet. Euh pour qui
avez-vous voté aux dernières élections
européennes ?
Ah ben je ça ça regarde personne, je
fais ce que je veux.
Question d'internet. L'effondrement
est-il une solution pour réduire nos
impacts ? Euh, ça c'est une question à
laquelle je vais répondre.
Monsieur choisit ses questions.
Oui, tout à fait. Euh c'est
l'effondrement de quoi ?
L'effondrement alors je dirais un
l'effondrement économique et puis deux
le tout petit effondrement écologique.
Ouais. Alors les
on s'en fout, c'est pendant 30 ans.
Non non non.
les l'effondrement économique. J'ai j'ai
répondu tout à l'heure, c'està-dire
qu'une crise économique majeure, je
crois que c'est pas une bonne solution.
Euh
parce qu'en fait l'histoire montre très
clairement euh quand vous regardez les
émissions de gaz effet de ser mais en
fait comme tout est corrélé c'est assez
fort vous voyez que les crises
financières les guerres ont un petit
effet alors c'est dans l'autre sens he
elles ont un petit effet de de de de
décroissance puisque en fait elles ont
un effet sur le PIB à l'époque au moment
où elles se produisent mais sauf que
l'histoire montre que ça repart juste
après donc
avec une hyperconsommation énergétique
voilà
on est toujours sorti des crises par une
hyperconsommation énergéqu Et donc donc
je crois pas qu'une crise je crois pas
qu'une crise financière
c'est elle va elle est il est très
possible qu'elle arrive. Je je crois pas
du tout qu'une crise financière résout
le problème parce que on va tétaniser de
trouille devant cette crise financière
ou
on pourra pas partir sur une
surconsommation énergétique derrière
pour sortir de cette crise ?
Bah on verra par la surconsommation
énergétique on pourra en reparler hein
mais parler tout de suite.
Ouais non mais ok il y a encore
énormément de charbon donc
c'est ça le problème.
Bah oui on est bien d'accord. Est-ce
qu'on va sortir avec la finance qui va
sauver la planète ou est-ce qu'on va
sortir de cette crise en continuant
comme en 40 ? Est-ce qu'on va choisir le
le chemin de la facilité ? Non mais donc
j'ai répondu moi je crois que pour
répondre à à la question internet, je
crois pas qu'une crise économique
financière standard soit dans la nature
à résoudre quoi que ce soit parce que
elle va créer du stress, elle va créer
euh des réflexes pavloviens et elle va
pas être du tout de nature. Ce que je
propose là hein qui est de dire il y a
tout un plan de bataille à mener euh
c'est des choses qui sont réfléchies un
peu. C'est pas des choses qu'on fait
dans la panique généralisée. Donc j'y
crois pas. Après la deuxième question
c'est est-ce que l'effondrement total ça
résout le problème ? Alors c'est encore
pire. Si on est à l'effondrement total
c'est qu'on a pas résolu le problème.
Autre question d'internet.
L'exploitation du gaz de chist est-elle
encore rentable financièrement parlant ?
Alors je suis pas un spécialiste de ça.
Le de de ce que j'ai compris et de ce
que j'ai euh pu percevoir de cette
affaire de de gaz de chiste aux
États-Unis, j'ai cru comprendre moi que
ça a jamais été tellement rentable et
euh sur le plan strictement économique
hein, c'estd que mais je suis pas un un
un spécialiste très profond de ça. Le
seul truc que moi j'ai dit et qui m'a
toujours paru assez évident, c'est que
si vous croyez les uns et les autres que
le fait que le gaz de chis soit pas
rentable, ça empêche
l'extraction, la production du gaz de
chiste, c'est que vous vz pas dans le
monde réel.
le monde réel américain, c'est que euh
si euh
l'État américain et les dirigeants
considèrent que c'est stratégique,
euh il ils s'organiseront pour financer
et même si on dit que les l'Amérique est
un pays libéral, ouais, enfin pas tant
que ça quoi.
Alors, autre question d'internet. Dans
quel secteur faut-il investir pour
réussir une transition écologique ?
Dans tous les secteurs d'activité.
Moi, je vais vous poser une question.
Dans quel secteur faut-il investir pour
réussir à faire un peu de pognon
dans tous les secteurs d'activité ?
Je suis pas conseiller en patrimoine,
faites ce que vous voulez de votre
argent.
Euh en revanche, non, c'est une question
importante. On a travaillé sur euh ce
que serait une France zéro émission
nette 2050 pendant quelques mois et ce
qui est apparemment évident, c'est que
euh tous les secteurs d'activité sont
appelés à évoluer et de manière assez
massive. Et ceci a un rapport avec cela.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
que le le le trou de l'ozone était
résolu par l'éradication des des
chlorophocarbone là, les les les gaz
furés. Finalement, c'est une grande
victoire euh écologique mais sur un
problème qui était infiniment plus
simple qui était j'avais un un coupable,
il fallait que je l'éradique et on a
fait un accord international. C'était
une belle réussite quand même. Mais là
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué. Tous les
secteurs d'activité sont concernés. le
transport, le l'industrie, le bâtiment,
euh l'agriculture, la forêt est concerné
aussi par la question et
on va privatiser l'ONF, c'est bien.
Oui, je suis pas sûr que ce soit une
solution au problème.
Euh, autre question d'internet.
Alors, que pensez-vous de la théorie de
l'effondrement ? On en a parlé.
Plafonner les fortunes pour éviter toute
inégalité économique. Est-ce réaliste ?
Euh pour limiter toute égalité
économique ou
Ouais.
éviter.
Ouais. réaliste, je sais pas ce que ça
veut dire parce qu'en fait tout ce que
je dis depuis depuis une demi-heure où
je sais pas le temps qu'on parle, ça
peut être considéré comme non réaliste.
Donc
ce que ce que je crois en revanche,
c'est que
je crois ce que je crois en revanche,
c'est qu'il y a quelque chose de très
irréaliste,
c'est de penser qu'on va régler euh la
crise écologique et notamment la crise
climatique sans s'occuper du tout de la
question des inégalités sociales. Ça, je
crois que c'est très irréaliste. Et
donc, de mon point de vue,
un un un programme écolo
qui prend au sérieux le sujet et donc
qui va être obligé de dire aux classe
moyenne,
on va vous alqui,
ça va être un petit peu plus compliqué
maintenant qu'
vous inquiétez pas, ça va passer mais ça
va faire mal.
Voilà, je je crois que c'est un peu
obligatoire de de de traiter cette
question. Alors, je je vais le
reformuler encore autrement parce
qu'après en terme de solution, est-ce
que c'est euh plafonné
de manière radicale les patrimo enfin
les donc en gros ça vient de dire faire
un ISF qui est 100 % au-delà d'un
certain niveau. Ça je pense c'est un
tout petit peu excessif. Je suis pas sûr
que on ait besoin de ça. Euh je suis pas
sûr parce que le sentiment euh
d'égalité, le sentiment d'inégalité,
c'est un truc un tout petit peu fin, un
peu délicat et je pense pas que ça se
traite de manière aussi grossière que
ça. Maintenant,
je reviens à l'histoire de la taxe
carbone parce qu'on m'a souvent dit la
taxe carbone c'est un truc injuste et
donc faut trouver un dispositif soit pas
faire de taxe carbone, soit faire un
truc qui bon je réponds souvent à ça euh
même toujours. Euh un instrument fiscal,
il a un objectif. Donc euh l'objectif de
l'instrument fiscal qui s'appelle Tasque
carbone, c'est de c'est d'inciter les
gens à moins émettre de CO2 et c'est
c'est d'inciter l'industrie à fabriquer
des solutions moins carbonées. Bon, si
le sentiment global collectif,
démocratique, c'est que la société est
du coup insupportablement inégalitaire
parce que ça c'est un on rajoute un
impôt indirect dans un dispositif
quelconque, à ce moment-là, il faut
mobiliser d'autres instruments fiscaux.
Donc l'impôt sur le revenu, l'impôt sur
la fortune. Donc il faut il faut faut
faire bouger les lignes de sorte que le
l'équilibre soit soit soit soit soit
rétabli.
Autre question d'internet. Les marchés
financiers sont-ils en mesure de
survivre à une décroissance ?
les marchés financiers sont euh ils
peuvent comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
un un un un un un p au casque euh
très vite. C'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure. Quand je disais tout à l'heure
les régulateurs sont un peu inquiets de
l'idée qu'on aille trop vite dans la
transition, c'est exactement la même
chose que ça parce que leur inquiétude
c'est que les marchés financiers sont
très autoréalisateurs. Donc ils vont
très vite, sont très moutonniers et donc
si tout d'un coup les marchés financiers
perçoivent que des entreprises des
activités carboné c'est mal et que ça a
plus la côte euh il y a des effets de de
boomerang terrible et donc ils peuvent
ils peuvent aller brutalement euh
vers les crises.
Alors autre question internet. Monsieur
Grand Jean, que pensez-vous des
mécanismes de reproduction idéologiques
que sont les écoles de commerce et
autres établissements scolaires privés ?
Hm.
Euh alors, il y a il y a il y a ce que
je pense et il y a ce que je fais. Euh,
vous
faites pas ce que vous pensez ?
Euh ben pas forcément non. Euh mais par
parfois si. Et donc euh mais a des fois
je pense mais il y a des fois je pense
des trucs que je fais pas.
Et vous aussi je pense vous aussi je
pense qu'il y a des fois vous pensez des
trucs et vous les faites pas.
Et donc le mot la pensée, c'est un truc
un peu compliqué. Donc non je je par
exemple à Dauphine
la pensée c'est un peu compliqué.
la la Dauphine euh carbone 4, on est en
train de faire des cours sur le la
finance et le carbone dans l'institution
Dauphine. Bon, on n pas réussi à faire
ça à l'ess et à Chauser. Je pense pas
que ce soit impossible de le faire mais
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui
pour ça pas été possible
parce que il y avait on a pas trouvé, on
a pas réussi. Quoi
de quoi ? C'était trop archaïque la
perception c'était contre leur dogme.
C'était quoi ? Les grandes écoles de
commerce, les grandes business school
nous disent qu'ils ont un un modèle à
défendre qui est un modèle de
compétition internationale et dans
laquelle dans dans le cadre de ce
modèle, il faut qu'il produisent euh je
vais dire un peu cash là, il faut il
faut produisent des élites qui qui ont
qui cochent toute une série de cases.
Donc ça veut dire que leur programme
doivent être tel que l'élite qui est
sorti de ces grandes écoles, les
business school doit être capable de
faire ça A B C D cocher tout série de
case quoi. Et ça c'est une compétition
internationale. qui disent du coup ça
bouffe entièrement le programme et donc
si on commence à mettre des trucs de
culture générale ou des trucs qui ont
qui cochent pas certaines cases bah ça
marche pas parce que c'est du temps
perdu et donc il risque de perdre des
des c'est alors évidemment c'est
totalement euh euh fantasmé cette
histoire là. C'est-à-dire que la le le
le c'est d'une opinion qu'ils ont sur
leur sur leur sur leur pratique.
On vous refera une émission sur les
grandes écoles. Euh autre question
d'internet.
Les trillions de monnaies inutiles qui
tournent sur les marchés financiers
spéculatifs représente-t-il un risque
imminent ? Ça, on a déjà parlé.
Euh, imminent, j'en sais rien. Je suis
pas madame Soleil.
D'accord.
C'est pas une blague. Euh
quoi que vous êtes pas madame Soleil ?
Non, ça c'est ça c'est c'est pas une
blague que je suis madame parce que vous
avez une boule de cristal super
optimiste, hein, quand même. Ça va bien
se passer.
J'ai pas dit ça. J'ai pas dit ça. J'ai
pas dit ça. J'ai pas dit ça. En tous les
cas, ce qui est sûr, c'est que ça serait
si on savait prévoir le moment de la
crise financière.
OK. Euh
c'est mathématiquement pas possible en
fait.
Si on parlait des agences de notation,
ouais, pourquoi pas.
C'est des scribbouillards. C'est quoi ?
Ils ont Comment ça se fait qu' déjà
agen de notation d'abord ils ont
Comment ça se fait ? Comment ça se fait
déjà qu'après 2008,
il y en a certaines qui toujours pignon
sur rue avec les anneries qu'ils ont pu
balancer ?
Ouais, c'est très c'est stupéfiant.
C'est stupéfiant.
Vous auriez fait quoi ?
Euh je je alors moi c'est pas un sujet
dont je me suis occupé à titre
personnel, mais ce que je pense c'est la
première des choses, c'est de comprendre
pourquoi ils ont un tel pouvoir
réglementaire. C'est-à-dire qu'est-ce
qui fait que euh quand je fais une
émission d'une l'émission d'une
obligation euh en gros je dois avoir euh
je passe par les foucoudin de une des
trois une des trois agences et c'est le
marché est fait comme ça. Je à vrai
dire, je ne sais pas exactement pour
quelle raison mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est pas juste une opinion de marché.
J'ai j'ai vraiment l'impression que
c'est des institutions
qui qui survivent grâce à ça. Donc c'est
vraiment complètement hallucinant.
Alors, il y a il y a une explication
peut-être culturelle, mais je suis pas
sûr de ça, qui serait de considérer que
passer le choc, passer de 3 ans de
qu'est-ce qu'on a transpiré,
c'était on est quand même passé loin,
qu'est-ce qu'on a été mauvais.
C'est pas absolument impossible de
considérer qu'il y a pas mal
d'économistes qui se sont rassurés en
disant "Non, mais finalement, c'est un
truc complètement exceptionnel. En gros,
c'est comme des stages solaires que ça
nous arrive circuit, il y a rien à voir
en fait."
Et donc on reprend business as du je
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a de ça parce
que dans les si je prends un exemple
très très sûr là c'est c'est la question
de la titrisation. On sait que la
titrisation a été un des leviers de
propagation de la crise financière. On
sait que ça a été quasiment arrêté. Si
si ça a été quasiment arrêté. qui est
beaucoup intricien et là ça repart à
toute vitesse. Ça repart à toute
vitesse.
Donc le fait que la tisation reparte et
que même l'Europe soit en train de se
dire il faut refaire la tisation parce
que évidemment par exemple les PME sont
mal financé aujourd'hui et donc on va
faire le marché unique des capitaux et
puis on va redévelopper la tisation pour
que les PME puissent se financer. C'est
juste complètement lentant. Donc c'est
comme si on avait tout oublié, espèce de
d'oubli complet de d'amnésie et donc on
titrise les prêtaméricain en ce moment
et évidemment c'est pour ceux qui qui se
disent il y a un risque de d'explosion
financière de crise financière majeure,
ça en fait partie.
Euh si on parlait des stress tests
bancaires,
des stress tests bancaires, c'est une
bullshit bullshiterie dans la bullshit
factory. C'est c'est quoi ? C'est pour
c'est pour se rassurer entre copains,
c'est pour rassurer les opinions
publiques.
Alors actuellement pour ceux qui ont pas
suivi ça, il y a eu des stress tests au
moment où on avait vraiment très très
peur de la crise.
Il y en a eu beaucoup de stress test et
il y en a eu plein et puis il y a des
boîtes qui ont qui ont fait faillite des
banques qui ont été sauvées par les sous
du contribuable alors que le stress test
était euh était pas mal. Et donc à
l'évidence euh il y a un tout petit
problème avec le stress test, c'est que
mais ça giro l'explique très très bien
dans l'illusion financière, c'est que si
le stress test est crédible
et donc il annonce le fait que la banque
est est souscapitalisée et risque de
planter, elle plante le jour même.
Donc ça va pas quoi.
Et si on fait un stress test sur le
système financier, qu'on annonce à tout
le monde qu'en gros c'est pas stable, il
plante dans la journée.
Ouais. pas peut-être un stressest du
système financier. Ça je pense personne
soit sérieux. Oui. Non non mais voilà.
Non mais non le stressest bancaire en
tant que tel pose un problème de fond
euh un problème théorique quoi. Euh
est-ce que est-ce que il manque pas un
peu dans le système bancaire pour pour
ne pas montrer leur perte ? Est-ce que
il y a pas un peu de de mythomanie dû à
la peur ? En fait c'est un peu comme un
gamin de 5 ans qui planque qui planque
sa petite connerie. Sauf que là c'est
une grosse grosse connerie. Est-ce qu'
Est-ce qu'il y a pas un peu de mensonge
de on s'arrange avec la vérité, on fait
du window dressing ? Non. Euh
euh ouais, c'est difficile de de dire ça
de manière très très générale. Il est
sûr et certain euh sil y a un truc qui
est sûr qui est la théorique,
c'est que ça magouille.
Non non, c'est pas la magouille.
Le Libor, le ribor c'était pas non non
mais ça je je discute pas ça à 5
minutes. Évidemment qu'il y a eu plein
de Tout le monde le sait. Donc tout le
monde pas non.
OK. OK. Bon, donc on peut en mettre une
grosse grosse couche sur les phrases
absolument insupportables des des des
qui ont été révélé successivement.
Ça renforce l'argument que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure qui est que croire qu'on peut
régler le problème de la crise
écologique sans régler ces problèmes là,
c'est quand même un peu naïf puisque les
gens s'en souviennent quand même. Donc
même si tout le monde tout le monde ne
le sait pas, il y a quand même beaucoup
de gens qui ont une perception très
aigue du fait que il y a des amendes
énormes qui ont été faites et il y a des
des des des
dérives complètes qui ont été faites. Je
pense qu'il y a une perception un peu
diffuse de l'opinion sur ces terrainsl
quand même. de même qui a une perception
un peu diffuse que les pratiques
d'évasion fiscale d'optimisation fiscale
des grands groupes, c'est quand même un
petit problème. Bon, alors maintenant,
savoir dire si aujourd'hui alors
deuxièmement deuxièmement un bilan
bancaire ou un bilan d'une compagnie
d'assurance c'est vraiment pas une
science exacte. Ça c'est clair.
Ça se maquille facilement. Bah je vous
employez le terme que vous voulez mais
en tous les cas l'appréciation
de les provisions sont suffisantes donc
le bilan est sincère c'est c'est il y a
une très grosse marge d'appréciation et
donc dans le domaine de l'assurance
c'est très connu ça je connais pas mal
d'exemples mais là je les donnerai pas
où l'appréciation l'appréciation puisque
le métier d'assurance c'est de passer
son temps à courir des risques et donc
sont imprévisibles
qui sont imprévisibles donc ils font des
calculs acturiel ils font plein de trucs
c'est prévisible
Non, c'est pas prévisible de manière
déterministe, c'est prévisible de
manière stockique.
Euh autre question d'internet que je
vais transformer. Euh donc la question
initiale était : "Avons-nous les
capacités cognitives pour faire face à
la mondialisation ?" Et je vais
transformer cette question en en la
suivante : est-ce que le monde
financier, le monde politique a les
capacités cognitives de faire face
à la crise de réchauffement climatique
selon vous ?
Ouais. Ouais, c'est une très bonne
question. Euh moi ce que je crois c'est
que l'argument de la complexité
qui est dire le monde est complexe donc
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est
un bordel tellement complexe que on va
on va arriver à rien. Je pense que c'est
c'est pas un fait de nature. C'estd que
on a fabriqué de la complexité et ça a
arrangé pas mal d'acteurs de fabriquer
de la complexité. Et donc c'est vrai,
j'aurais peut-être dû le dire ça tout à
l'heure j' a pas pensé mais mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que un des gros avantages
des dispositifs qui sont pas mondialisés
préjangistes et tout est dans tout et
réciproquement c'est-à-dire d'avoir des
trucs un tout petit peu plus structurés
c'est que c'est plus appréhéendable et
on arrive mieux à comprendre le le le
dispositif. Donc je crois que les
je vais prendre un exemple très concret
pour me faire comprendre. Au moment de
la crise 2007-2008, la crise des
subprimes,
j'ai j'étais économiste, je suis
toujours, j'ai appris des trucs en terme
d'information qui étaient vraiment pas
du tout connus. C'est-à-dire
bah par exemple qu'il y avait des CDO au
carré, il y avait il y avait des
produits dérivés extrêmement compliqués.
Je le savais pas et je savais surtout
pas la quantité invraisemblable de
milliards qui traînaient dans ces trucs
là. Bon et donc la complexité euh permet
de de noyer le poisson sous un flot
d'information considérable et et
effectivement je crois une très bonne
question parce que je je pense que
l'acte euh les actes politiques visant à
simplifier un peu sont de nature à nous
aider dans cette sursaturation et dans
cette inaccessibilité cognitive.
Maintenant, l'autre argument qui est on
a on est dépassé par le réchauffement
climatique, donc nos capacités
cognitives ne permettent pas de d'y
faire face. Ça, je suis pas sûr hein. Je
je crois que il y a il y a beaucoup de
de pédagogie, il y a beaucoup une
question de psychologie de la pédagogie
beaucoup plus que de que de capacité
cognitive intrinsèque parce qu'en fait
infiner ça se résume à quelques
informations pas très compliquées.
Euh autre question, le Haut Conseil pour
le climat a été créé en décembre. Vous
en êtes où 6 mois plus tard ? On va
faire un rapport qui va être qui va être
rendu en demin
19. L
ceux qui voudront le lire, ce sera euh
diffusé sur internet euh et ce sera
adressé au gouvernement avec un devoir
de réponse de sa part euh dans les 6
mois. Donc euh on verra, on discutera
avec les députés, avec l'Assemblée
nationale. Ouais. Oui. Non mais bien sûr
mais là
c'est pas un peu pissé dans un violon
quand même peut-être. Est-ce que c'est
est-ce que est-ce que faire des groupes
de travail comme ça, est-ce que c'est
c'est quoi ? C'est pour sauver le monde
ou c'est pour se faire briller en
société ? Ça sert à quelque chose ? Euh
là, j'ai besoin de 2 minutes pour
répondre à la question. Ah,
vous pouvez même prendre trois hein.
Euh j'ai animé le comité des experts du
débat national sur la transition
énergétique en 2013, début du mandat
Hollande, donc ça fait 6 ans. Euh ce ce
débat là était très utile, je crois. il
a il a permis de à pas mal d'acteurs de
de de s'approprier le le sujet de ceux
qui étaient concernés par le débat
évidemment et il a il a été préparatoire
de la loi de transition énergétique qui
est une loi très importante dans le dans
le cadre français qui a
pas du tout des anecdotes.
Euh cette loi instaure des budgets
carbones à l'anglaise.
des budgets carbon anglais ça veut dire
en gros on fait ce que j'ai dit j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure de la stratégie
nationale bacarbone donc le fait que on
se donne des objectifs par période sur
la réduction des émissions de g n de la
France c'est pas anecdotique parce que
si on se les donne bah ça donne quand
même une orientation c'est ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure il faut pas avoir
peur des gros mots ça c'est une forme de
planification évidemment que dès qu'on
est en train de se dire il faut qu'on
ait un vigil
qui dit est-ce qu'ils sont tenus ou pas
ces budgets et ce vigil
a été là aussi on a copié les anglais
parce que le dispositif existe comme ça.
En Angleterre ce vig c'était le climate
change committe le CCC. Le le le
dispositif anglais fonctionne et il y a
pas mal de preuves qui montrent que ça
marche pas si mal. Bon, parle que du
Brexit, mais si on parle des questions
de réduction des émissions de gaz en
anglais en Angleterre, c'est un des pays
qui fonctionne le mieux qui ça vraiment
fonctionner et et donc le haut conseil
pour le climat, il a c'est pas du tout
une réponse aux gilets jaunes, c'est pas
du tout une réponse à une crise
politique quelconque. C'est une
institution qui a été pensée réfléchie
il y a 6 ans dont la première version
qui a été installée par la loi de
transition dont j'ai parlé donc en 2015
a pas fonctionné parce que ce comité que
vous connaissez pas qui était un comité
d'expert il a pas été posé dans le débat
il a pas été installé il a pas on lui a
pas donné de moyens et du coup il a rien
faiton donc la création du haut conseil
pour le climat c'est juste
la création d'une instance
dont le la vocation, la mission, c'est
de dire au gouvernement là tu as fait le
job, là tu as pas fait le job, là tu
nous as dit qu'il fallait faire telle
politique et ben moi je te dis que
celle-là elle a pas marché, celle a
marché. Donc moi je veux bien tout
C'est quoi vos moyens de pression ?
Bah donc moyen de pression c'est que le
gouvernement doit exprimer euh doit nous
répondre et doit il doit nous dire si on
lui fait des recommandations, s'il les
prend pas, pourquoi ? Et donc notre vrai
moyen de pression, c'est l'indépendance,
notre crédibilité, le fait que don là,
je parle pas de moi, là, je parle de du
du du comité lui-même et de Corine
Lequeré qui est qui est la présidente et
qui a passé des de qui est une
climatologue très très reconnue et qui a
fait ce job là en Angleterre et donc la
capacité de de bien installer cette
question là dans dans le dans le paysage
et dans le débat. Si on n'y arrive pas,
bah on aura on servira à rien. Donc moi,
je si je fais partie
Vous êtes payé pour ça ?
On est payé 500 balles par euh par
journée de travail.
Et vous bossez combien de temps ?
Euh entre 1 et 2 jours par mois.
Fait 1000 balles quoi.
Ouais, c'est ça l'idée.
C'est déclaré.
Ah bah évidemment.
OK. Autre question d'internet. Les
économistes sont-ils condamnés à
commenter à postériori des crises qu'ils
n'ont pas su prévoir ? Euh ils sont bon,
il y a beaucoup d'économistes qui font
des commentaires euh beaucoup. Moi moi
je
sur BFM
et donc j'essaie depuis qu'on se parle
tous les deux là de pas faire que des
commentaires.
Vous passez sur BFM ?
Euh j'aime pas cette chaîne.
Bah pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il faut le temps de
l'explication, le temps de
l'argumentation. Et d'ailleurs euh c'est
quand même une bonne un bon point euh
dont j'ai pas du tout parlé, donc c'est
pas mal qu'on en parle maintenant, mais
c'est que il est il est tout à fait vrai
que dans la situation de stress actuel
euh
dans le plan d'action générale, avoir
des médias qui font un job un peu
sérieux, de tant d'explication,
de temps d'argumentation et de temps de
développement, c'est tout à fait
fondamental. Tout tout tout comme il est
tout à fait fondamental que dans les
écoles euh nos gamins euh réapprennent
le culte de la tension euh de la
concentration euh soit pas euh soumis à
ces tablettes numériques dès l'âge de 3
ans et demi euh qui vont leur en
l'air le cerveau quoi. que évidemment
que que les médias
suputez vous suputez sur le fait que les
tablettes parce que sinon on va voir les
les fournisseurs de tablettes qui vont
dire alors nos tablettes ça fout du
l'abus de de tablettes trop tôt l'OMS
dit que il faut pas donc il il y a des
standards médicaux là-dessus
on arrive à la fin de notre interview
changer de forme pour voir s'il y a
d'autres questions. Vous m'accordez une
petite seconde.
Ouais. Ça
le nucléaire, on en fait quoi là ?
Bah, il y a il y a une il y a une loi
qui qui a en cours de discussion sur la
durée à partir de laquelle il faut le
faire décroître de
Ça discute beaucoup l'écologie en fait
hein.
Ouais, ça discute beaucoup. Ouais. Mais
là en l'occurrence le nucléaire c'est un
truc très controversié puisque
évidemment vous avez d'un côté le fait
qu'il aimait pas trop de CO2. Donc c'est
une manière de faire l'électricité qui
aimait pas trop de CO2 et d'autre part
il y a plein d'inconvénients. Bon donc
il y a des arbitrages à à réaliser. Mais
numéro 2, la raison pour laquelle moi
sur le nucléaire je suis assez
pragmatique quand même
c'est que
euh le remplacement
dans une stratégie de lutte contre un
gens climatique
arrêter le nucléaire à l'instanté si
c'est pour le remplacer par
des énergies fossiles. une idée moyenne.
Donc il faut trouver les bons
calendriers, les bons pas de temps
qui permettent de faire une sortie de
sorte que on atteigne nos objectifs
climatiques. C'est pas tout à fait
évident.
Autre question d'internet, est-ce que le
RSE va-t-elle sauver la planète ? La RSE
?
Alors ça c'est la responsabilité sociale
et environnementale. Donc c'est un
mouvement qu'on voit beaucoup dans les
entreprises avec des directeurs ou des
directrices de la RS dans les
entreprises avec beaucoup de RSE washing
comme on a fait du green washing et donc
je je veux pas dire du mal des des des
personnes qui sont en charge de ces
boulot parce que c'est c'est un boulot
très difficile en fait puisque elles
sont au cœur de plein de contradictions
dans l'entreprise
de la bonne RSE.
C'est-à-dire, si je prends un exemple
fiscal qui est que sur lequel j'ai pas
mal discuté avec Cécile Renoir, l'idée
que si vous êtes responsable comme en
tant qu'entreprise, vous devez votre
responsabilité va jusqu'à la question
fiscale. Bon, est-ce que avoir des
pratiques fiscales d'optimisation dans
tous les sens
de de de prix de transfert qui sont
adaptés de manière à avoir aussi peu
d'impôts possible ? Est-ce que ça c'est
responsable ? Je crois que non. Donc une
bonne RSE qui qui mettrait tous les gros
sujets euh d'ordre de responsabilité
fiscale, euh d'échelle de rémunération
au sein d'entreprise euh de pratique euh
insupportable dans au sein de avec des
risques de souffrance au travail. Je
pense que ça c'est utile. Est-ce que
aujourd'hui on fait ça ? Je pense que ça
dépend beaucoup des entreprises.
Bon, Pierre Laroutou, il vous a piqué
votre idée que vous avez eu il y a 10
ans.
Alors, il a fait pire que ça. C'est que
moi, on en a pas du tout parlé là, on
aurait pu développer longtemps. C'est
que bon, ça fait très longtemps que je
dis que la création monétaire, c'est
quelque chose qui existe, qui est bien
connu, bien compris et donc il y a pas
de raison que comme chaque année on crée
de la monnaie, il y a pas de raison que
cette création monétaire soit peu
utilisée à bonne fin. et dans le euh en
la matière pour faire pour financer les
investissements écologiques. C'est
création monétaire se fait soit au
niveau de la banque centrale, soit au
niveau des banques secondaires. Euh là
où euh j'ai un petit débat avec Pierre,
c'est que c'est pas tellement qui les
idées sont pas ma sont pas ma propriété.
C'est très bien euh que ça circule et
c'est très bien que lui, il a réussi à à
faire passer l'idée d'une manque du
climat. En revanche, la les dispositions
qu'il a mis en avant avec Jean-Jousel
euh moi me me paraissent pas très
convaincantes. C'estàd que le traité le
traité le pacte finance climat avec
l'idée que je fais un traité d'abord que
je que je que je je dont j'obtiens le la
la signature, c'est une idée qui est pas
réaliste. On fera ça se passera pas
comme ça. l'idée de faire une banque au
niveau européen, on n pas besoin de
créer une nouvelle banque parce qu'en
fait au niveau européen, il y a la BEI
qui fonctionne, il y a la BDE et donc ce
qu'on a surtout besoin, c'est que ces
banques orientent leur financement dans
le sens mais on en a parlé tout à
l'heure, c'est ça dont on a besoin. Et
troisièmement, les dispositifs de
refinancement qu'il a qu'il a qu'il a
suggéré sont pas complètement
performants. Seul temps, c'est ce qu'il
a fait très bien, je trouve et très
utile dans le débat public, c'est de
mettre ce sujet sur la table de manière
à ce que ça devienne un objet de débat
et qu'on puisse se dire bon c'est quoi
les bons les bons
les bonnes organisations qui permettent
que la création métaire se mette au
service du Cuma. Donc ça de ce point de
vue-là, c'est bien.
Voilà. Une question quit de la
décroissance contrôlée.
Je redis moi ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure, je recommence. le PIB pour moi
c'est pas un bon indicateur. Donc la
décroissance du PIB à je m'en fous
complètement. Ce qui m'intéresse c'est
qu'on ait des dispositions des système
d'incitation et des règles des normes et
et des mécanismes économiques qui font
que les activités qui sont destructrices
de l'environnement on les fasse de moins
en moins et que les activités qui sont
réparatrices, on les fasse de plus en
plus. C'est ça qui est intéressant. Le
PIB en tant qu'indicateur, ça c'est
c'est tellement mauvais euh que ça nous
avait nulle part des croissants au
croissant. Alors, une question qui vient
de la Réunion. Que pensent-til de la
propriété privée ? N'est-ce pas l'unique
solution pour la transition ? Est-ce
qu'il faut remettre en question le le
droit à la propriété privée ?
Alors, ça c'est une très bonne question.
Ma ma tendance là là-dedans, c'est de
dire qu'il faut remettre en question
idéologique selon laquelle la propriété
privée est la solution à tous les
problèmes. C'est ça le truc. Euh il y a
des communs, euh il y a des sociétés qui
vivaient très très bien avec des
arrangements communautaires. Euh c'est
très connu après les travaux de Léner
Strom là-dessus. Et donc l'idée très
générale qui consiste à dire la
propriété privée et la solution à tous
les problèmes et par exemple il faut
privatiser euh les émissions de CO2 pour
faire des marchés de quota parce que bon
tout ça c'est des c'est des des
bullshit. Euh donc je pense qu'il y a un
travail euh théorique qui est en train
de se faire parce que il y a de plus en
plus d'universitaires et de de penseurs
et de gens qui réfléchissent à cette
question-là qui est donc euh dans quel
cas il faut euh sortir de usus abusus et
fructus euh de de et les dogmes de la
propriété privée. Après, je suis pas
collectiviste et donc je crois pas que
la solution soit de dire je reviens à
une collectivisation intégrale. Donc je
pense qu'on va trouver des nouvelles
modes, des nouveaux modes d'organisation
communs.
Voilà,
on arrive à à la fin de notre interview.
On a pour tradition de vous laisser
donner un conseil pour les jeunes
générations. Une bouteille à la mer,
quelque chose qui restera impérissable
sur internet. Impérissable ça. Euh les
jeunes générations,
moi je ma ma ma mon conseil principal
c'est faites tout ce qui est dans votre
possible pour garder de l'autonomie
intellectuelle et matérielle.
Ne vous faites pas avoir par des
dépendances queles qu'elles soit.
C'est pas que le monde sera plus dur
demain qu'il est aujourd'hui, mais c'est
que vous aurez besoin de cette de cette
éonomie dans dans le monde de demain.
Vous aurez besoin de l'autonomie
intellectuelle pour pas prendre des
vécis pour des lanternes. Euh vous aurez
besoin d'autonomie intellectuelle pour
comprendre la complexité de ce monde,
pour comprendre pourquoi il y a des gens
qui pensent A, d'autres qui pensent B.
et vous aurez besoin de l'autonomie
matérielle qui consiste à ne pas être
dépendant de surconsommation,
d'addiction et de choses où peut-être
quand même la vie demain sera sur ce
plan-là un peu plus difficile qu'avant.
Donc moi je je dis ça tranquillement
parce que c'est comme ça que j'ai élevé
mes enfants.
Non non, je suis déjà vieux dent mais
j'ai élevé mes enfants dans cette avec
mon épouse dans dans ce style là et j'ai
des enfants dont j'ai pas le sentiment
qu'ils sont en train de faire une crise
de tétanie
s'il y a pas la tablette de 4e
génération pardon. Je reparle de
tablette s'il y a pas le dernier gadget
à la mode à la main. Voilà.
Alain Grandjan. Merci.
Merci beaucoup à vous.
[Musique]